e
e e
so
good morning today is Tuesday February
4th 2025 this is the New Hampshire House
of Representatives Municipal and County
government committee I am representative
Diane power the committee has convened
today for public hearings on 10
bills now please make sure that your
cell phones are silenced and please join
us in reciting the Pledge of Allegiance
led by representative
France alance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you before we begin today I have a
few morning
announcements so the committee has
convened today at 9:30 for public
hearings after the public hearing that
is scheduled for 11:30 the the committee
um plans to break for lunch then public
hearings will resume at 1
p.m. I'm going to actually pass around
the committee contact list I I forgot
last time I announced it but didn't pass
it so again just please cross out your
name if you do not want your contact
information shared just with the
committee so I will pass it this
way so one other quick thing I wanted to
mention is in order to make the very
best use of our time in committee the
chair has decided not to have the clerk
call roll call attendance due to the
fact that a quorum is not needed for
public hearings however the clerk does
record attendance um at the beginning of
executive sessions which is not
applicable for today and I do believe
that the ranking member is in agreement
with this and she's not here
so as I said we're here and we're going
to have public hearings on on 10 bills
so in order to stay on schedule the
chair will allow for up to 5 minutes for
Bill introductions followed by questions
and
answers and the chair will also allow up
to three minutes for in-person public
testimony with additional time allowed
for questions and answers if the speaker
allows if we have a lot of pink cards
for for a particular Bill the chair the
vice chair will keep track of time he's
in the meeting right now that's why I
was not present here because we have
weekly um meetings at um at 9: so the
vice chair will keep track of the time
and you may hear like a a buzzer go go
off or the speaker should look for a pin
card if the speaker has written
testimony please indicate that and
distribute it to representative kazinski
if you have copies and we'll pass it
along the table so that all members get
your written testimony if a speaker
um the time the three minute time is
imposed and you run out and you have
more information to communicate please
um let me know and then follow up with
the committee with any additional
information you'd like to provide um
emailed to all the committee members
each Committee
Member finally as a reminder
to members of the public that provide
in-person testimony here today please
remember to State for the record your
name who you represent and your position
on the
bill I don't have that laminated um
reminder card here because we're in a
different
room so when the clerk is ready we will
begin our first hearing
I have to do the vice chair's job here
just one moment
at this time I will open the public
hearing on House Bill
689 enabling municipalities to adopt a
volunteer incentive property tax
credit so um I assume you're the prime
sponsor representative is it Hemingway
Hemingway yes um did you fill out a pink
card I did not I'll fill one out okay
thank you so miss representative
Hemingway welcome to Municipal and
County government thank you madam chair
uh members of the
committee today we're going to talk
about the house bill 6 89 this is a
enabling Bill relative to volunteer
incentive tax property tax
credit uh this
bill is directed towards the elderly and
the veterans
uh these are two groups that have
incomes that are normally limited and
have a low propensity to be able to add
income unless they get a job uh and at
that age and uh and sometimes with the
disabilities of a of a veteran they're
limited on the type of jobs that they
can
get
um why why would we want to use the
elderly and the Veterans for their
knowledge the reliability and and their
you know uh care for the
community this B Bill benefits both the
municipality uh and the volunteer the
community gets help uh in areas that
they have limited uh support such as in
the community centers as in with the
area beautification admin or in event
planning for certain events for certain
things within the community um the
volunteer gets the benefit of
interaction with the personnel within
the community plus they also get a sense
of Pride for working with the
community
uh so as of right now uh as a quick
search I found uh five places five
states that do offer something of this
sort uh Mass Main New York Oregon and
Pennsylvania uh again this is a uh
enabling bill so the communities can
choose to adopt or not to adopt uh the
monies would have to be put into an
overlay just as he would for veterans
credit and to uh support that um deficit
the other benefit that you could also uh
say that this would be is it helps
reduce the
part-time
uh
income the the
um part-time uh expenses uh for an
employees since you're not having to pay
them and you're paying no benefits and
any other thing they're only getting
$1500 tax credit on the on their
property as a
relief uh I'm available for any
questions if anyone has any at this
time thank you representative Hemingway
for that bill introduction um questions
representative Walker yes thank you
madam chair uh so they get 725 an
hour until it adds up to
1500 but how
the expense of keeping track of it all
who's going to do that in the
municipality and why you know I did yeah
um thank you for your question uh
representative um so the the
recordkeeping should be at the location
where they're actually doing the
volunteerism and if that were to shift
then their record should shift to the
other entity that they're working at uh
and I I believe 725 is a little bit low
I I would probably recommend going a
little bit higher just to
I know it says 725 yes correct but I I
would be uh amendable to a increase on
that additional questions representative
Gilman thank you representative for
taking my question uh this bill also
needs a an amendment I believe under uh
because it's added a reference to RSA 72
39- c which this committee found in
expedient to
legislate okay um well I know it's
supposed to amend the 70 it 72 39 yep 39
C uh which which would go in there so
that's the amend amendment of that
correct and when was this
found was one of our first
sessions it was this year
I don't remember what date we did it's
110 I believe this is the first I've
seen it on the
docket but no I'm I'm talking about
another bill oh okay that we I believe
it was one representative Gilman the the
reference here in the bill is to uh a
statute and not a
bill correct but they've added into the
bill into this um into this Bill a
reference to uh RSA that we already
found an expedient to legislate in HB
1110 I
believe additional
questions representative
grundt thank you madam chairwoman thank
you for taking my question um to add on
to what representative Walker was saying
in small smaller towns like things like
so we have an Amherst Garden Club that
takes care of all the gardens around
town There's No location that of anybody
tracking who's working where so I think
the concern of we have people
volunteering we have people who help
take care of trails in our town people
there's no central location would add a
cost to these towns for someone to sign
off and verify this work's being done so
the question is what kind of Burden
would that add to a town if they're not
prepared for that thank you for the
question I I don't think it would be
that great of a burden and and maybe um
because they have to register by the
first of April to say that they're going
to be using this incentive so it would
either be have to be through the um
admin section or the the uh Finance
section of of the M municipality Andor
the assessor's
office because I only say the assessors
only because they would keep track of
the proper the and and finance will keep
track of the the taxes
so additional questions representative
frock thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question
representative um mine is a two-part
question if I may uh firstly I am aware
of
many uh tax exemptions that are
available to disabled veterans
and I think veterans in general and I'm
wondering if this is in addition to or
instead
of uh thank you for your question
representative uh this would be an
addition to okay M may I ask my second
part yes you may thank you um second
part there are a lot of towns and a lot
of older people and Veterans who have a
lot of
knowledge through their life experience
through their work
whatever um why would this bill not
apply to people who volunteer their
times their time to serve on the many
Town committees and
Boards thank you for that question uh
the committee's uh boards and and uh
advisory uh those are those are elected
positions or positions that are people
have applied for so that would not be
part of this because um you would think
right because you need more people we're
we're short on some of our boards and
everything it would incentivize people
to to get involved
but that's that's
their they do that those boards and
committees for a reason and those
reasons is to help the community and
being an elected or an appointed
official is not the same as saying I'm
going to volunteer down and imp plant
flowers or help with an event planning
so I mean they're they're they're there
to strictly guide and and direct the
town in certain directions to make them
better whereas a volunteer is there to
help in those processes to get the town
there sure
the chair recognizes representative
Colby thank you madam chair um on page
two lines 10 and
11 uh States qualifying persons while
providing such volunteer services shall
be considered employees of their city or
town for the purposes of RSA
um
what what do you have any idea what the
effective insurance is um the additional
costs that maybe a municipality would
have to take on um or training that the
uh employee volunteer would have to go
through uh thank you for your question
um I do not know the if there would be
any extra cost because I think it would
just be covered under um comprehensive
or Andor
um injury um
injury uh Insurance whatever so I don't
think there would be much of an increase
if there was any at
all further questions represent oh
representative
Elward thank you madam chairman and
thank you for taking my question um
relative to the followup with uh
representative
Colby's question about being an
employee um would they be issued aen 99
by the
town thank you for your question I I do
not believe so since this is a it's not
they're not getting paid they're only
getting an abatement or a or a tax
incentive so it's not like they're
getting a physical paycheck and the the
uh I'm trying to remember where the
break line is for
a1099 um I don't know if it's if it's
900 or a th000 600 600 so but they're
not getting an actual pay they're
getting a deduction in their tax so it's
it it would not be a 10 to9 1099 in my
opinion thank
you the chair recognizes representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman and I
I think I'm piling on with the same
question is is I'm I just don't
understand why they even need to be
employees and curious if that was your
language or if that was recommended by
ol
thank you for your question I believe
that was that was that was not my
language that was inserted in there but
I mean You' have to look at that as okay
they should have the same um not
benefits but the same knowledge that
this person if someone were to come up
to him say hey what are you doing here
well I'm I'm working for the city
helping them do this and you know so
that would I think it's more about
recognition than it is you know and in
case of any liabilities for insurance
purposes followup I don't usually do
follow-ups thank you so does that mean
that the volunteer would have to be
working in conjunction with something
that the town or city
recognizes as as volunteer or can they
volunteer for something else
non-affiliated and and submit that as
qualifying volunteer time does that make
sense yes yes thank you for your
question um now it has to be in line
with what the what the city has so if
you have a a part-time spot within the
community center and you want to have
someone go in there and check IDs or or
you know collect monies and things like
that um if you have a uh a group that
does area
beautification um that's sponsored by
the city then you know they could
participate in that if have an event
planning process or or team that's
sponsored by the city then they could be
involved in that but it has to be in
with the city's purview thank
yes representative
Gilman thank you madam chair I have a
correction and a question um the bill
that I was referring to earlier was uh
HB 101 which we have not made an
executive decision on um
then the question
is there is there reference in here
regarding
um personal information that um
volunteer may get access to
no the chair recognizes representative
grund thank you madam chair woman uh at
what point would a volunteer position
cross into becoming an employee for
example um someone volunteers to clear
sidewalks maybe they're using a city
vehicle to do that damage cause what
point is an person an employee versus a
volunteer thank you for the question um
I don't I don't think that for one the
volunteer will be driving any any City
vehicles um because that would be higher
liability and the training I'm sure
depending on any pickup truck or a car
yes sure that's fine but there's still
liabilities and they still have to be I
know in the military we have to be
certified on on whatever we drive
whether it be a a a Coleman lantern or
or a lawn mower or whatever we still
have to be licensed on that uh and
improve training so um I don't foresee
that that would would happen and if that
did then they would probably have to go
off the volunteerism incentive and move
into a part-time position or a full-time
position and that would relieve the city
of the overlay that they have yes thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Walker for a
question so you got the April 1
deadline excuse me so if I sign up for
this before April 1st but I don't do any
volunteer work till it's warm like May
or June do they get the tax credit and
they just you're hoping they work it off
or uh they have to wait till the
following year thank you for your
question you have to wait until you
actually do the work uh because it's
it's on a cost per hour basis so as as
once you start you can sign up in April
and say you're going to do it but
nothing may be available because you're
not you don't like to shovel snow or
whatever and you'd rather mow Lawns or
or you know trim so you wouldn't you
wouldn't have any uh cost shearing into
that until you actually do the work on
an hourly basis and then that's kept
track to and when you reach that limit
then You' get your incentive on your tax
bill further
questions representative
Colby thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question question um
again uh I'm just trying to understand
the difference between an employee and a
volunteer would an employee if we are
treated them as
employees would the employee
policies within the
town be applicable to the
volunteer um for instance background
checks uh or um drug test testing
or um anything else that a municipality
may require from their employees thank
you for the question um if by chance
that's where they needed that person
then I would suppose so but I would I
would anticipate that most of the
volunteerism would be in areas that do
do not have to worry about those types
of background checks and and uh other
training that they may need um because
you're looking at you know Community
Center um um maybe helping out on on an
event down at the park you know that's
City sponsored or you know those types
of things so it's I don't foresee that
that's going into those
positions the chair recognizes
representative Murphy for a
question thank you madam chair thank you
representative for taking my question
it's actually a two-part isn't this a
form of Bing and what are the IRS
implications of this thank you for your
question um
I suppose you could call a type of
bartering um I do not know what the IRS
uh um impact on this would be because
you're getting you're getting a a
discount on
your um your your property tax so you
don't really report that to the IRS
and you can also I mean but you're
getting you're getting an incentive so
could
you put that in as a charitable donation
on your IRS I would say you have to TA
talk to a tax attorney on that um but
with the thresholds being so high and
being an elderly and a and and a veteran
uh probably you wouldn't reach the
threshold to do a itemized
deduction and you'd probably end up
taking a standard deduction so there
probably wouldn't be much but again I
would I would consult with a tax
attorney
additional
questions seeing none oh representative
um
Colby uh just for clarification on page
one um I would say lines 8 through 12
the it states no resident shall receive
a total property tax credit greater than
1500 but yet it can be
combined with any additional credit or
exemption that they already qualify for
so if my municipality has a
$750 all veterans tax
credit is the
total that they're
allowed to achieve 1500 so that veteran
would only be entitled to another
750 uh to get
to I'm just confused as to the the
language so one says total greater
than but it has to be in addition to in
a combination with okay thank you for
your question and thank God your your
municipality gives 750 for the veterans
credit if they do um so this is this is
a in addition to so they get the 1500
plus the 750 so thank you yes thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you thank
you next the chair calls Mr Jim
mow welcome to Municipal and County
government that's better um thank you uh
committee chair and committee members uh
my name is Jim misho I'm Chief assessor
for the town of Hudson uh want to make
clear that my testimony not just on this
bill but on all the bills I'm going to
testify on today do not necessarily
represent the viewpoints the board of
selectman for Hudson uh they haven't
registered any opinion on these bills to
date so um consistent with prior
testimony on bills this year and in
Prior sessions I usually um testify to
the technical administration of these
bills um I do have written testimony I
will not uh go over verbally all of the
written testimony um but the first point
um deals with a weakness in the bill and
that's um how many different variations
of these volunteer tax credits there can
be so when you think about what you uh
work with at the local level you have a
veterans credit of
$500 um you have a double veterans
credit of a th000 those are defined
amounts this at $1,500 Max is$
150,000 different variations of a tax
credit right if you can fractionalize an
hour and and you come up with all these
different combinations
our Mass appraisal systems software
systems they can't handle that many
different combinations um your tax
collection software that also cannot
handle that many different combinations
so if this was structured that it was
more finite if I put in 10 hours it
would be a $250 credit flat right
something that we can um easily more
easily have in a bucket right so imagine
that these are buckets in the two
different software systems um they're
just not set up to handle all the
different combinations that this would
entail
um it states that it's a tax credit for
veteran and elderly um but it's not just
veteran and elderly there's references
to disabled veterans totally and
permanently disabled there's references
to disabled uh people that are social
security disabled so um I don't know if
additional language to clarify that
right in one part it says this and
another part it expands on
it um I think someone touched on this uh
vol ER volunteer tax credits um would
this deplete existing committees and
boards that people serve on which they
do not get compensation and they might
turn around and say I think I'll leave
this and do some volunteering you know
might that have an impact upon um your
local efforts to fulfill your Municipal
boards and committees um an unattended
impact possible um as far as limiting
the overall fiscal impact of the program
so in Hudson we have about 1273
between veterans credits elderly
exemptions totally and perly disabled if
just half of those folks uh put in a
volunteer effort at $1,500 that would be
almost a million dollars in tax credit
that would be shifted over to all the
other taxpayers in the community um it
doesn't decrease the amount of money as
we know locally right it just it's a
shift um and I'm not sure if that's
considered a limited limited fiscal
impact it's not a limited shift in the
impact um so imagine Manchester versus
Marlo right we have some issues of scale
with
this um does the tax credit get divided
between two tax bills if you're a two
tax bill Community we do do that right
um but it doesn't state that that's the
case um in other statutes it's stated
that um in no way shall the combination
of uh exemptions and credits turn into a
situation where the community is paying
the person right so not only is there no
zero Bill they're actually going to get
check from the municipality that
language is not in here um there are
other statutes so you can pull that
language in if you want to uh choose to
amend this and um to wrap up um I know
in 2010 and this is my written testimony
uh House Bill 1489 was a proposal to
adopt a volunteer incentive property tax
credit um that was found itl by the
committee back then uh and the house was
a Voice vote itl as well I'm not saying
passes prologue um but this committee
legislature has looked at this issue
before um and then subsequent to that
there was a bill dealing with uh
volunteer firefighters and having them
work some kind of tax credit in um and
that didn't that didn't pass muster
either that's the gist of my questions
Madam chair thank you for your testimony
questions for Mr
Misha seeing none thank you thank you
so that was the um one and only
additional pink card beyond the um Prime
sponsor so I will ask is there anyone
present who wishes to speak to this bill
that has not yet had the opportunity to
do
so seeing none I will close the public
hearing on House
Bill 689
I apologize um I forgot
to indicate representative Gilman to
report out the blue
sheets but you can do that
now thank you madam chair in today's
blue sheet the uh one uh representation
is
neutral the online testimony is three in
support and seven
oppose thank you
okay we're we're doing well on our
schedule so at this time I will open the
hearing on House Bill 766 enabling
municipalities to adopt an exemption
from the local education property tax
for certain elderly
residents the chair recognizes
representative MC Mayon to introduce the
bill welcome to Municipal and County
government I apologize McMahon
good morning members and again thank you
for the opportunity to speak before you
on Hospital
766 the reason for this uh bill that I
bring to the table uh is the goal of
providing an environment
of allowing our aggressively mature
population otherwise known as elderly to
stay in their homes uh I'm also a
professional realtor and I've uh this is
my 12th term at the state house and what
I've learned over time is in planning
for a reality future in uh in the
context of identifying the need and then
providing Avenues of opportunity uh
increase the quality of life and
relative to uh this bill we have U found
that our uh Elders that uh have
committed to their towns for decades and
would like to stay in their town and I
would like to they choose to but
ultimately when the economics play a
role uh a higher authority ends up
influencing what the decisions are uh
they end up leaving the leaving town and
and many times leaving the state and uh
as we all are aware as representatives
and Senators the housing challenge we
have in our state is uh front and center
from the governor on on to us as well
and it's the meeting meeting that
challenge is what I bring to the table
for your consideration here uh
specifically this is the uh this is a
goal the goal here is to provide an
Avenue by option of the cities and towns
who know their population best to uh
reduce the obligation in this case of
the school property tax which is the
biggest impact on our tax bill for for
our elders who have and PR a bill uh as
the states a qualification is those who
are 70 years in of age and older have
lived in their residence for 30 years
and also a criteria is have uh no more
than
$750,000 in saved assets and now saved
meaning a savings and um as other bills
that you may have seen in the past uh
their vehicle would play a role in in
the asset base as
well the uh key becomes is paying paying
their bills um inflation that we're
we're dealing with and uh in other tax
tax effects uh has made it a challenge
for our elders to stay in stay in their
homes and the choices of where to go uh
is uh in many of our smaller towns is
not to promote
um
overdevelopment you know and
overdevelopment that's been the concept
and building infrastructure know four
apartments and that's it's not been it's
been a challenge and especially in also
in where I live I live in Windham New
Hampshire I grew up in Salem and unless
you have an infrastructure in place uh
for uh water and sewer you do not find
competitive low rent opportunities uh
it's just that's just the cost of doing
business for our housing so so again
this opportunity here is when town are
looking to find ways of um maintaining
costs and uh also is not to have U
population uh growth based on an exodus
from the towns when uh other other costs
in the town can U make being affordable
for a for elders to stay in town uh the
opportunity here is to give a uh the
school um a batement for those who would
qualify that the town did would
determine by their own census and that's
a census of those what they've owned in
town and and meeting the criteria that
has been specified and the longer they
live in town then we have a slower
change of ownership and by slower that's
my assumption looking at what's happened
in towns that I've done research on as a
realtor uh is that they stay in their
homes for longer and that when they're
sold when families move in and with and
bring and we want families to come to
New Hampshire but in in an uh a gradient
method of not overpopulation uh that our
cost of education is substantial per
student this would delay that and and
delay it or for a period of time where
it becomes slower in in the growth
mantra for our respective cities and
towns and and to keep these folks in the
towns that they love that they've
supported and uh one of the points of
the 30 years was just using 12 years for
if uh when they had their own kids in
and they've been contributing to the
cost and of sustaining and maintaining
our school districts uh the again the
biggest majority of our tax bill is for
our schools is that this will allow them
to stay in in the town and not um being
part of what's the other challenge we're
looking at right now not right now have
been is um nursing home assisted living
and capacity in our counties and with
those costs that differential cost still
comes into our tax uh calculations is I
offer that this strategy is one for the
for towns and cities to opt in if the
demographic makes sense for them and
hope and I'm suggesting that it does and
that we keep people in their homes
longer and for that reason I ask for
your uh your consideration for this
opportunity thank you madam chair thank
you for the bill introduction questions
the chair recognizes representative
Walker for a
question how is this proposal exactly
Fair because I had a constituent that
asked a similar thing and I asked him do
you have any kids when you were younger
he goes yeah I have three kids and I go
hm there was an elderly person at that
time that paid for your three your three
kids to go to school but now that when
you're elderly you don't want to pay pay
into your share what somebody else did
and now how is that
fair it's the cost of doing something
versus doing nothing representative
Walker the the issue becomes and uh and
I'm just going on my back on what I've
learned here in the legislature is the
cost of being in a nursing home which we
cover in our taxes or or other costs
when they when our citizens don't remain
in their homes uh is is substantially
higher and I don't have the have the
cost of demographic the present to you
today on that but that that's I by the
way I agree with what you're what you're
talking about I want a fair and and
applicable obligation for all of us and
but the fact of the matter is that's not
the fact of the matter and the reason is
the cost of Education being our biggest
expense even for our smaller towns in
the state of New Hampshire when they
have Cooperative school districts our
elders are there's many of the elders
that I've spoken with and that's where
this comes from uh cannot afford to stay
in their homes any longer
and so that's why for this consideration
it's not it's to have a more orderly
growth replacement than having an exodus
that's what people leaving that people
our fellow citizens leave leaving the
state because they cannot stay here any
longer and or with their families as
well and so this is one that can they
stay in their homes longer and help
facilitate that by main uh maintaining
their costs on their own but with this
uh tax abatement for on the school side
only I still would cover the the
property tax for for the town you know
County and Etc but um on the school side
that's why it was focused on the school
only that they did support for 30
years and that's where the number comes
from thank you the chair recognizes
representative majority for a question
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
for taking my question um I'm originally
from New York my father when he was
alive uh uh there's a program down there
called the program and he was able to
have $7,000 of his tax taxes deferred um
because of that program so I'm wondering
and certainly that was a benefit to him
I'm wondering if you have modeled this
legislation after any other state like
New York which has the star
program thank you for the question um
your
honor rep
representative I was want to address
everyone formally um the uh the answer
is no I did not um what I've learned is
what I've learned in New Hampshire I've
grown up here and uh learned from my
colleagues where I want to assimilate uh
in an intelligencia that allows for
rational recommendations to meet the
future challenges we have in state so I
did it's called the Stark program star
star excuse me I I'm apologize but no I
did not utilize that thank you further
questions the chair recognizes
representative
Guri thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question representative I
like to talk talk a little bit about the
30-year limit you have and I understand
what you're trying to do as far as keep
people in their homes but would this be
uh I don't know if it's not fair but it
wouldn't be better if we required in
this legislation that the people live in
the town uh my my concern you know and
we're neighbors I'm from Hamstead and
I'm just thinking of myself
and uh I
downsized uh and I moved into a a uh a
park with the uh instead of instead of a
regular house but I stayed in the same
town so I would qualify for being in the
town for 30 years but I didn't live in
the same house for that 30 years is is
it would it be uh would would this have
been uh fairer if we had said that the
person should be in the living in the
town for 30 years because that's where
the tax was being
paid well that's a debating Point
representative and the issue uh right
here is that you you already chose to
move I me again the goal here is to keep
people in their homes so it didn't open
up the home for New frankly for new
families to move in with with their
children and then to expand the costs in
the other in the education uh Silo um
but if that's something that you wanted
to that the board would consider then
for an amendment on this I mean that's
that's why we talk collaboratively to
achieve consensus on what would be what
would work if something like that would
be improved but the target of this bill
was to keep people in their homes and
with then have the sold their home if
maybe I hope you you got a good sale on
your home that you had the that asset
then becomes an income stream for you
and then you can lower your fixed and
variable cost of living then you you've
met that challenge it's there are those
who don't or can't do that or to would
ra would rather is there a way of
staying in their home and and also one
other point is one thing we do very
substantially in the state is home
Community Based care and that's again to
maintain folks in their home with you
know with Health visits and you know
doctor visits and so on as as opposed to
being transferred elsewhere elsewhere
meaning that again nursing home or
hospital setting so that's what just
incenter his Force for for this criteria
unless you would recommend a an
amendment and that's I look to the uh
committee on that subject I understand
what you're trying to attempt thank you
very much for taking my question yes sir
thank you madam chair thank you thank
you the chair recognizes representative
grund and then representative
Dolan thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you for taking my question so is
there is there a way to I want to say
prevent or how do we account for if the
elderly person's kids who has grandkids
that go to the school are living in that
house now they're not paying any taxes
to the school even though they have
children in the school is there any
limitation for that that would be that's
why this is an option for the town and
the town can also make addition rules
for this again it's it's not to to uh
circumvent an obligation if the if
there's a specific use of that residence
in this case education to have the kids
living in so I mean that that's not what
this bill is
targeting may I have a quick followup
yes thank you so how would a town know
that a family is living there and not
and they have kids in the school but
they're not paying taxes because the
elderly I mean they can't they're not
taking an assessment of who's living in
a household well I'll just speak on my
behalf I'm a past 12E selectman in my
town of wiam and when uh we were doing
but like for just for services and
support and also education you had to
always say where did you live in town
and you would and have to qualify that
you're an actual resident and then it
would be collaborated and Co cerated in
working together to ensure that yeah so
again because folks have we're looking
at
and I'm I'm aggressively mature myself
here but the uh back when we first got
started there were those moving from out
of state and we uh were using the
education resource and this was like
maybe five that took place this is like
25 years ago and um that was identified
when a census was being taken and where
individuals live so a similar scenario
would would be the case when you're
having a a benefit of this of this and
that's a people in their to keep people
in their homes of people when I say
people the owners whove lived their 30
years in their
homes thank you the chair recognizes
representative Dolan for a question
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my
question as I look at this I see that
we're trying we're trying to save or
help the elderly uh with their tax bill
um but I I'm assuming that that tax bill
that the elderly won't be paying is
going to have to be picked up by others
in the community uh and I wonder if
there is there a potential un unintended
consequence here of in in in the context
of the housing crisis that the state is
is uh seeing are we shifting this tax
burden to the younger people in the
community that already are struggling to
pay their their taxes and is that an
unintended consequence that that you
consider uh yes that was and um as as
one who's looked at U not looked at has
worked hard and not always successful at
having a balanced tax base established
in a respective Town based on uh on
future planning of what's coming in your
town in this case like in the town of
wiam when we used to go to uh to S to
for schooling to Salem OR to and then to
pinkin uh we we had our own School
District coming in that's been the
biggest impact in the town of wiam and
what the town and this is where the town
chooses what to do is their policy still
was not to allow Economic Development to
take place to meet the additional costs
and and we have zoning that does not
allow over overdevelopment either so
this is a town responsibility on
determining what's the best thing for
our the respective Town Council or
selectman to determine to do and cost
wise savings would be approximately
$9,000 and when you're looking at uh
from our tax rate it's in what the Imp
would be and I don't have the exact
number um but the impact would be in the
sents as in pennies you know for that
difference in in a revenue stream being
made up and we're not and and we have in
our town and we have have a fellow U
gentleman that have worked together on
this bill as a constituent who's going
to speak a little bit to this is that uh
it just in in dealing with how many
Elders that would qualify for this it's
a very small it's a small demographic
graic uh I was trying to get it to OS
they didn't have it to all towns I mean
I have all the tax assessments but
couldn't get that population uh but
that's where it comes to the respective
town has the the determination to see if
this makes sense in keeping th their
citizens in town and also a way of
controlling the the biggest uh cost
impact on growth is is when more
families move
in thank you for the answer um I would
just remind anybody that's going to
speak don't repeat the same answer to
different questions because we've
already heard that information and we we
do have additional speakers so the chair
now recognizes repres representative
Colby for a
question thank you madam chair and I
might be able to uh help you
representative a little bit um in
Windam uh we have age 65 and over you
have
2542 residents as of 2022 the most
recent I have here in
2024 65 plus uh elderly
exemptions uh were $12
million I'm how do you anticipate that
number
growing well
I I I didn't get that information there
but uh what I've done in
uh here was dealing with those again who
were 70 and older and been in in their
homes for 30 years and that's where that
demographic is has quite a dramatic
impact on the what that real number and
the number that my associate came up Mr
Morris who speak shortly uh was
approximately 140 and one thing that we
didn't get down and I was uh I wanted to
be fully loaded intellectually for you
but I would could not get this down was
how many was seasonal so you know so
fulltime and then in Windham we have
know carets Pond and so on but was not
in so many other of our towns where um
properties that are owned by our elders
but they're not their primary residents
and uh so that 140 plus did not account
for how many are seasonal but that's
where that research comes in dealing
with our the with how that's interpreted
on uh U by by the cities and town so
this isn't a circumvent or to force a a
a mandate from the state onto our cities
and towns it's here's an opportunity and
a framework for performance that to help
for the reasons already
stated but thank you for that
representative
kby
followup thank you madam Sher um just
lost my train of thought but uh if you
would like this might help you out I can
pass that down um don't we already as
municipalities don't they already have
an option um to adopt an elderly
exemption um and could they within those
elderly exemptions
modify uh to make things more uh
palatable or affordable uh for people in
their
communities there there are and by the
way wiam has has one as well but it does
uh what it is it it goes to uh reducing
the total of the assessment which in in
wham's case and our average is $900,000
a home um is
$200,000 that does not I mean does not
have a material and uh impact on
providing fund enough funds now this is
in my view which is why the bill enough
funds for these Elders to again to pay
to pay the the their cost of living and
one of the um ISS issues on that in the
qualification is that you can't be over
$300,000 in assets and this is in nwn of
Windham and that just went up literally
this past uh well within the last 12
months we don't have people qualifying
for that you know and and so now when
I'm and the reason the 750 came I I was
reaching out to other time when I see
reaching out doing the research and uh I
we got that recommendation um after
reviewing it from Brookline and uh from
like similar find like similar towns and
that wanted again to maintain their
citizens who supported their town to
stay in their homes and controlling
growth as a result but hope that answers
your question thank you ma'am
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman uh I think section six
answers my question but I just want to
be sure it it talks about the the owner
of the property we have a couple of
bills in housing that deal with adus
accessory dwelling units am I is it safe
to say that if the owner of the
property qualifies say one year Builds
an Adu and moves into that Adu and say
their kids move into the main residence
that the ex like this would then
disqualify them because they have moved
into the Adu and that's not their actual
residence that would be my sense okay
all right yeah I appreciate the Technic
that the very specific Adu issues both
attached and detached as you know we had
on bills coming right uh not coming but
voted on but you're right sir no that
would not be okay qualification thank
you further questions I have a quick
question you had mentioned in your bill
introduction that you said the ton will
will vet recipients I may have missed it
but would a resident need to apply and
qualify and the the point that I'm
making is is is this automatic or does
would the recipient actually need to
fill out an application and and show
some sort of proof that they fulfill the
qualifications uh
your yes it it's an application function
and uh for review and compliance by the
authorities having jurisdiction in the
town and specifically the assessor I
would say the the
assessor in filing this bill did you
consult with Dr uh yes matter of
fact uh a number of entities I don't
have the notes in front of me here honor
but uh yes I
did um further
questions representative
Gilman thank you madam chair I just
wanted to follow up on the um the
question about family that lives in a
house and has children that are going to
school but the house name is in the
30-year resident um would
there's a would there be
a discussion between the town's assessor
and the
schools uh attendance records that will
add on to the burden of the
assessor asking a question that would
add a burden to an assessor that's to
with all respect that's not a burden
that's what the assessors are supposed
to do and and I would say that that's no
not a burden but it would be a a
question of ownership and
occupation U I mean uh who's
occupying the uh the property and that
would be what the uh bard of selectman
of the Town City Town Council would
ensure would be the rules for those who
would qualify for uh for this ex this
exemption have a followup Madam shair
quickly yes um so if I understand
correctly the select board would set
rules that say uh if a child uh
grandchild is permanently res resident
of that property then uh this no this
does not qualify to the person
applying I would say the at this point
outside of a revision on some wording
that that's the intent of this it's not
the circumvent or U taxation that's
appropriately obligated again this is a
housing issue to keep our elders in
their
homes yes
ma'am further questions seeing none
thank you thank you madam chair thank
you committee at this time the chair
recognizes Mr Jim
Misha welcome back good morning Madam
chair and committee members thank you
for the opportunity to testify for the
record my name is Jim misho Chief
assessor for the town of Hudson what I
said prior holds My Views don't
necessarily represent the views of the
board of selectman for Hudson they have
not registered an opinion on this bill
um speaking to the administrative
aspects of the bill um it's looking for
communities uh to be able to adopt an
exemption from the local T education
tax but we don't know what the local
education tax is each is each year until
we issue the bill so how do we Grant an
exemption on an unknown number
we can't and that's why um the bill as
written just doesn't work it will not
work procedurally
administratively um this is not uncommon
with some of the bills that come in
front of you not just this year but in
Prior years we have to understand how
the tax administration how the tax bill
process works we have to know what our
total vet credits are we have to know
what our total leld exemptions are our
total disabled exemptions because all of
those get loaded into the tax rate
calculation process that dep that the
Department of Revenue um administers
each year um that's the gist of my
testimony um but beyond that um in
reviewing the bill it's not clear if the
exemption is in addition to any prior
exemptions that apply to the bill you
know we already have an existing elderly
exemption program does this pig pile on
top of that I don't know um I assume it
does um beyond that the asset amount of
$750,000 there's only one community in
the state that has an elderly exemption
program existing um that has an asset
amount of
$750,000 that that's a pretty high asset
limit um there's no income limit for
those that are applying for this so um
asset tested but not means tested as far
as income as far as the range of elderly
exemption asset amounts it ranges from
the Dom Minimus 35,000 up to what I said
the
750,000 uh the median asset limit is
63,000 the average asset limit is 9
1,600 this is all from nhdra online 2023
tax year um I believe that the varying
amounts of assets probably reflect that
there's different socioeconomic uh areas
in the state right Pittsburgh might be
different than Portsmouth permont might
be different than pelum um
so beyond that I have no other comments
and I'm available for
questions questions for Mr
Misha seeing none thank you thank you
okay so I have one final pink card and
this um it's from Mr Wayne
Morris so the chair recognizes Mr Morris
welcome to Municipal and County
government yep okay um good morning
committee members uh my name is Wayne
Morris I'm from wendam um first like to
thank uh representative McMahon for
sponsoring House Bill
766 as well as my four other Windom
representatives and representative W
Wier as
co-sponsors um as representative mcmah
has pointed out uh House Bill 766
attempts to allow senior citizens who
have made a
commitment for over 30 years or more um
to their Community to stay in their
homes I'm going to change glasses here
yeah there we
go um just as a in
2023 uh the average age of a firsttime
home buyer in New Hampshire was 35 years
old uh in 20 2024 that age has increased
to 38 years uh with this in mind when
one looks at at the parameters set in
House Bill
766 the current new homeowners will have
paid school
taxes for the next 32
years uh in order to take advantage of
this elderly exemption while also
needing as you know to meet the asset
limit set out in in this
bill as firsttime home buyers in
1980 little could my wife and I imagine
we would be paying school taxes for the
next 45
years we have no issue with paying it
forward for well-educated
children but with retirement the meaning
of being on a fixed income has hit with
a new real had hit has hit hit us with a
new reality um House Bill 766 I believe
addresses the ongoing needs of an aging
population that still require Municipal
services such as police fire and EMS
perhaps even more than when younger um
as you know Municipal and state tax will
not be exempt from
payment overall the exemptions allowed
in House Bill
766 I believe helps stabilize a
community's tax base by keeping elderly
in their homes whereas if they need to
abandon
them because of the inability to keep up
with an ever increasing tax
burden new families with children on new
first home home to
firsttime home buyers planning families
in the future would replace them this
adds to the schools this adds to the
school tax
impact anecdotally the above scenario
was exactly what happened to my wife and
I over the 45 years we have been
residents of
wendam we once the new homeowners with
elderly neighbors we now see families
with children moving into our our
neighborhood uh which not that long ago
when there was
only um a handful of children at the
local school bus stop um we now have a
whole new generation of children taking
the same bus route my daughter took 23
years
ago Mr Morris yes would you be able to
um wrap up your testimony and I'm I'm
there okay thank you one more paragraph
um I would hope you I I would hope you
see House Bill 76 exist as a measure to
allow elderly residents who have shown a
commitment of 30 years or more to their
communities uh the ever increased um to
age in their own homes without the added
tax burden um which may force them to
make a decision to have to leave behind
a life uh started and nourished what
seems to be a a lifetime ago um thank
you um any questions I don't know thank
you for your testimony questions for Mr
Morris and and and just a remark to the
uh you know as far as the the uh the tax
burden being spread to younger
families I have uh you know my my
daughter was in in school for only 12
years um I've been paying taxes without
children in the school system for 26
years
um that is kind of you know spread the
tax burden to me for the people who have
children um so from that standpoint um
that that would be my comment in regards
to uh you know spreading spreading the
tax burden to other families I've been
it's been spread to me for 26 years so
um that's it thank you
sir so um thank you so I do I have a
pink card here and the bill number is
not a bill number um that we scheduled
to
hear
so is there a Mr Ben Saul here could you
raise your hand yes um what what Bill
did you want to speak on
65 could you amend your card and then
pass it back thank
you okay
so at this point I would like to ask is
there anyone present who wishes to speak
on this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none the
chair recognizes representative Gilman
to report out the blue
sheets thank you madam chair on the
remote signin we had one in support and
opposed and on today's uh blue sheet we
have uh two in in favor and one
neutral thank you and with that the
chair will close the public hearing on
House Bill 766
at this time the chair will open the
public hearing on House Bill 625
relative to enabling M municipalities to
Levy payments against nonprofits at a
percentage of their assessed property
values the chair now recognizes the
prime sponsor representative Bolton to
introduce the bill and I do not have a
pink card so when you're all set when
when you're done introducing the bill
just fill out a pink card and then pass
it
along oh okay it was it was tardy so
where is it
okay is just put this at the
end uh thank you representative Bolton
and welcome to Municipal and County
government
M red button would be helpful um Madam
chair and members of the committee my
name for the record is William Bolton
and I'm the representative of Grafton
house district 8 which is the town's of
holderness Ashlin and
Plymouth in addition to be a
representative I'm also the vice chair
of the Plymouth select board and I've
been on the Plymouth select board for
the past 12 years and I may just be
getting off we'll see um and in addition
to that I'm also the executive director
of Transport Central and transport
Central is a
501c3 it's an agency based in the whole
village building in the town in the town
of Plymouth and we provide non-emergency
medical transportation um at no charge
for elderly and disabled individuals
transport Central um serves a 19 town
catchment area with Plymouth being
centrally located our drivers use their
own vehicles uh there're dot
certified and in the past 11 years now
we have driven over 1.7 million miles
our Volunteers in carrying people to
their medical
appointments House Bill 625 was written
as an enabling legislation to reduce
property tax
numbers the burden rather of those
cities and towns with a large share of
nonprofit agencies such as Plymouth
according to the New Hampshire division
of Revenue administration's report 2023
comparison of full value tax rates
Plymouth is R ranked seventh out of 228
municipalities listed and seventh from
the
bottom um this is primarily because 53%
of plymouth's taxable property is owned
by non non- tax paying
nonprofits uh leaving all the cost of
the Town Services being paid for by the
remaining 47% of the property
owners regardless all the residents all
the businesses all the nonprofits
receive every benefit that is provided
by the town of Plymouth and is funded by
the town of Plymouth
taxpayers at Plymouth Town Meeting last
March I was asked to create a bill that
would um seek uh payments in Le of taxes
from plymouth's nonprofits that would
lessen the property
um you know the property tax impact that
Plymouth property owners are feeling
House Bill 625 is the a bill that
accomplished that and after some
investigating we found that other uh
cities and towns might also be affected
and and are we've had conversation with
town of Kean they have 22% of their um
you know uh you know 20% 22% of their
properties are nonprofit owned conquered
has 23 Anover has 35 and Berlin has
43 so this bill is enabling legislation
which means that the municipality must
decide to enact it or ignore it and if a
town wishes to adopt it the town shall
pass an ordinance by or bylaw to provide
an agreement between the municipality
and the
nonprofit the nonprofit profit May
provide for exemptions from the payment
and they can do this by um articulating
U Regional or local benefit and also
they may be able to describe their
financials aren't adequate to pay the
25% so that's up to the town to consider
and after consideration of the
exemptions the municipality may decide
to enact it and the nonprofit shall make
payments in lie of Taxation on all real
and personal property owned by the
organization in the city or town equal
to 25% of the municipal rate of the
property tax that would be paid if the
property were not exempt from
Taxation and I probably don't have to
explain but the municipal rate um of the
property tax is simply the the monies
that go toward support of the town it's
not um including education and County
taxes so 25% of that that
number um regardless I urge the
committee's passage of HP 625 and I'd be
glad to take any questions thank you
representative Bolton
questions seeing none thank you great
thank you so at this time I I have um
eight pink cards so there's eight
individuals wishing to speak to this
particular bill so many of you may not
have been in the room um when the
committee here started public hearing so
I'm just going to quickly review so for
subsequent speakers here after the prime
sponsor we will allow um up up to three
minutes for in-person public testimony
with additional time allowed for
questions and answers if um the vice
chair here is going to keep track of
that time if the speaker has written
testimony please indicate such and give
it to representative kazinski at the end
of the table there and we will
distribute it to the committee members
and importantly if a speaker has more
information that they would like to
communicate to the committee with
regards to this bill um also let me know
and please follow up with um something
written and email that to all the
committee
members so at this time the chair
recognizes Mr Tom blon
Blonsky welcome to Municipal and County
government is that better great my name
is Tom blansky I work for Catholic
Charities New Hampshire we are uh a
large Statewide nonprofit Human Services
organization that provides a huge array
of Social Services and Healthcare
Services to the poor and vulnerable
across New Hampshire We Run The New
Hampshire Food Bank serve a large
Medicaid population in our seven nursing
homes and senior independent living
apartments we also offer transitional
housing for Veterans and moms in
recovery sliding scale fee counseling no
fee light and intense case management at
our eight district offices caregivers
and manano at home programs that serve
fixed income seniors with free
transportation to medical appointments
and food delivery this is just a sample
of our Outreach we received referrals
from cap agencies in city and town
welfare department in and annually
provide just shy of $24 million in free
or reduced cost services to our clients
to tax us on top of what we already
generously contribute to the many
communities in which we're an integral
part would force us to either cut
services in particular towns or begin to
charge or to raise fees this would be
akin to instituting a regressive tax
where the ones who need our services the
most are the same ones who would be most
severely affected I strongly oppose the
passage of HB
625 thank
you any questions thank you Mr balony
questions seeing none oh sorry
representative
kby that was my fault thank you madam
chair
um would you could you give us some
insight on how um your services offset
uh cost to a
municipality so uh often when uh there
might be federal dollars flowing through
a particular quasi public agency um that
aren't timely uh we might get referrals
to help with rent assistance for example
or heating assistance or food assistance
um that happens on a number of occasions
um we've often seen in in City welfare
departments where um they're running at
a surplus and they should be payer of a
first Resort and they're referring to us
first before um there is any uh help
administered at the town or city
level okay thank you additional
questions seeing none thank
you next the chair calls Mr Peter Saliba
followed by m Kathleen
Reen welcome to municipal County
government thank you very much it's an
honor to uh be here today uh the Mayu
program was established in 1969 as a
501c3 we challenge and help at risk New
Hampshire boys to believe in themselves
work well with others and find their
best since 1969 we have helped 2,400
boys in the state of New Hampshire and
our family profile has an average in
come of about $29,000 a
year our boys mostly come from single
parent homes and what we do is we have
an eight-year program where they come to
Mayu during the summer and then during
the winter our Outreach workers meet
with each child at least once a month to
make sure that they're on track and we
reinforce the values that we're teaching
at Mayu we're the only program of its
type in the state of of New Hampshire
and one of two in the nation that works
the way that we
do we are against the passage of 8B of
HB
625 Mayu owns 39 acres of land that has
been assessed at
5,465 th000 which transfers into a tax
liability of approximately
129,000 at
25% that would be a
$32,000 liability
for our
operations 81% of all of our funding
goes to program and our boys the
remainder goes to
operations if we had a tax bill of
$322,000 it's likely that we would need
to eliminate 42 boys from the program
currently we have
220 and that's because we would either
curtail one of our camp sessions or we
would have to um uh eliminate an FTE one
of our employees because that represents
about 70% of one FTE in our
organization Mayu is one of the many
nonprofits that work hand inand with
state agencies to provide support on a
weekly basis we're in conversations with
DCF dhss and
doe HB 625 would hamper our ability to
provide services to our board
thank
you thank you
questions seeing none thank
you next the chair calls Ms Kathleen
Reen followed by Mr Brody
Des good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chair and members of the
committee for hearing me uh today for
the record uh my name is Kathleen raren
I'm the CEO of the N Hampshire Center
for nonprofits which is a nonprofit
organization that exists to strengthen
and give voice to New Hampshire's
nonprofits we have more than 800 members
and represent their interests here we
have strong concerns about HB 625 and
the implications that it will have on
nonprofit ability to serve our
communities as you consider the
legislation I would ask you to think
about a few things one is the important
significant role that nonprofits play in
our communities here in New Hampshire we
rely on nonprofits heavily for a diverse
array of services Services which in some
other states are performed by government
nonprofits are strong partners with
government providing services such as
those you've heard about today
affordable housing homelessness uh
Services Health Care Mental Health our
substance use disorder prevention and
more they are also drivers of our
economic Vitality um providing
stewarding our natural resources
providing cultural resources as well
they are a part of why New Hampshire is
such a great place for all of us to live
and and for people to visit as well in
addition most of New Hampshire's
nonprofits are quite
small according to IRS data um 70% of
our 501c3 have revenues or budgets under
$100,000 this kind of tax would be
devastating and may even bankrupt them
and as you've heard today even those
larger organizations it would have a
significant impact on their ability to
to perform their
services most nonprofits receive a lot
of their funding through funding through
restricted mechanisms and so they are
not able to Simply absorb these kinds of
cost
burdens finally I would add that our
statute already allows for Pilots
um and it is a local issue that
municipalities can negotiate in good
faith for voluntary payment in Lee of
taxes from nonprofits which is a bit of
a compromise because the reason that
nonprofits in the public policy decision
has been made for for nonprofits to be
exempt is in recognition of the
significant services that we provide to
the community so in closing I would just
urge you to vote this in expedient to
legislate um and I'm happy answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none thank
you the chair calls Mr Brody Dees
followed by Mr Henry
veu thank you Madame chairwoman and
thank you to the committee for taking my
testimony this morning um for the record
my name is Brody Dees I represent the N
Hampshire Municipal Association we are a
nonpartisan nonprofit that uh represents
um every municipality voluntarily in the
State of New Hampshire they're voluntary
members and they've chose to be members
um I'm speaking in support and
representing our position on um House
Bill
625 um our position is that this is a
local option it's the option of the
voters to allow 25% of the tax bills for
nonprofits to um to be paid um I want to
really point out that um that there's
there are Provisions in this current
bill that would allow the governing body
um Not only would they be required to
adopt an ordinance ordinance or bylaw
but it would allow them to still fully
exempt um nonprofits and charitable
organizations from paying taxes it just
allows a local option for the voters to
say Yes um the default is a 25% pilot
payment in Le of taxes and then the um
requirement of the governing body
typically the board of Selectmen it
could be a board of assessors though if
that happens if it is adopted in a
community to um to essentially um exempt
them fully still so this would create a
more local option and would allow for
governing bodies to really evaluate
whether or not a nonprofit or tradable
organization is um serving and bettering
the uh the public good in their
Community improving the public welfare
which municipalities have a duty to do
um I respect all the nonprofits that are
coming in front of you today in the
services that they provide um that said
at the same exact time we can only as
municipalities raise revenues through
property taxes and when we have member
communities where nearly 55% of their
assessed land is exempt from taxation um
that creates a a quite a um quite a
burden shift onto the other property
taxpayers and yes um it is it was
mentioned earlier and we couldn't agree
more that there's 7 RSA 7223 DN allows
for voluntary payment in lie of taxes so
it allows a voluntary system for these
organizations to to to pay um taxes to
the municipality but in some cases there
are times where governing bodies have
really questioned the charitable or the
nonprofit status of organizations and um
while they might be considered such by
the IRS um the municipality's question
whether or not their mission is
furthering some kind of public benefit
where they're completely exempt from all
taxes so we view this as a very modest
local control option um I think our One
technical thing that we'll point out is
that um it would be nice if in
establishing this new section of State
RSA that there's some kind of citation
that doesn't um it doesn't
um overrule um any existing um voluntary
payments and L of taxes under RSA 72
colon 23 DN or that it's explicitly
stated that that can still happen so you
could go both routes right if a
nonprofit want to pay more than 25% of
of a pilot um of its total what is its
assessed property tax um then it could
um if they wanted to pay less that could
be negotiated so allowing for this uh
this the these proposed statutes to not
overrule the existing 7223 DN so you
have kind of two local options so um
that would be our one recommendation and
I will um take any questions from the
committee if there are
any that was perfectly timed thank three
minutes on the DOT questions for Mr Dees
the chair recognizes representative
Colby thank you madam chair um do you
feel that this could possibly encourage
um being optional um and then still
allowing uh negotiations to happen do
you think it would encourage like
cherry-picking
organizations um I hear I hear that fear
um I would have some faith that our
governing bodies in the state would not
be playing favoritism and they would
probably run into lawsuits if they were
starting to do Viewpoint bias for who
they provide um property tax exemptions
to I think if they had a clear criteria
in a ordinance or a bylaw of how are
they going to determine this if if the
voters so if the voters in a
municipality or a city were to adopt um
the provisions of this law and it were
to require the governing body who
oversees the assessing of taxes whether
it's a board of assessors a board of
Selectmen or some other governing body
prescribed by state law um if they were
to go through that entire process um I
would imagine that they would adopt a
bylaw and ordinance that has a strict
and um a a strict and clear criteria for
what the qualifications are as to one
not to put burdens onto organizations
that are very clear compelling public
benefit to the municipalities or you
know maybe an entire region um but to
also recognize when there might be other
nonprofits that they exist and you know
they benefit maybe their membership but
there might not be a compelling public
interest for why they should be fully
exempt from taxes and in many ways this
will force organizations to the table to
say okay maybe we should help um pay for
some of the municipal services that are
being provided in this community because
everyone benefits from those services
that the municipality provides so this
is just looking for a creative way to
say there should be more negotiations of
Pilots it shouldn't be just on the
property taxpayers and those who are
living in mostly residences um to pay
for all the municipal services that
every organization and individual
benefits from so our stance would be
that this is um this is a way to allow
more more local control and discretion
of who should be paying I guess the best
way to put it for lack of better term
their fair
share the chair recognizes
representative majori thank you madam
chairwoman and thank you for taking my
question uh did I understand you
correctly that RSA 7223
n allows a municipality to do
essentially what this bill is doing it
allows but it doesn't have any
requirement that the um the charitable
or the nonprofit organization actually
do it so I I'll read the exact statute
to you it's 72 col 23- voluntary
payments in Li of taxes quote the
governing body of any municipality may
enter into negotiations for a voluntary
payment in Li of taxes we often call
that pilot from otherwise fully or
partially tax exempt properties and may
accept from such properties a voluntary
repayment in Le of taxes so they can but
there's nothing where there's a criteria
for the local governing body to
essentially kind of you know say is the
is there a compelling reason as to why
this organization is fully tax exempt or
doesn't make sense for them to
contribute some to the tax base for the
services that they utilize um within the
municipality so there is an option for
the organization the town to negotiate
something but the organization decides
it doesn't have any interest um in
negotiating it doesn't matter what kind
of services or what the um the purpose
is of the charitable or nonprofit
organization they can just say no we're
not contributing because we qualify
under existing state statutes as an
exempt nonprofit under 72 Co and 23 at
least they properties that qualify under
that
statute additional questions
representative
grundt thank you madam chairwoman thank
you for taking my question um trying to
just clarify all the different groups
that might fall under this provision so
looking at so we we've heard from a
couple not not for profits but this when
I'm looking at chapter
292 which goes into volunteer
corporations associations which is
referenced in the bill it starts talking
about literary scientific institutions
libraries promotion of Education Arts
Sciences hospitals homes for asan for
invalids
Freemasons uh grounds other conveniences
for bar
so are we talking about all of these
organizations they do provide
he you know Town Services these would
all be potentially subjected to this 25%
of the municipal rate if they qual I
mean my reading of the bill and let me
make
sure let me open up the bill
here yeah that would be U my reading of
the bill is yes they would be um 25% of
the municipal just Municipal tax rate
that's worth pointing out too so not
swept not school just Municipal tax rate
doesn't even include a v Village tax if
they're in a village area where they
benefit from Services I will say however
that's part of the purpose for the bylaw
and the ordinance requirement so they
may adopt a byw and ordinance and say
clearly you know a private library
because there are libraries in the state
that are publicly governed but they are
private property um with their own
private trust that you might say well
it's not worth taxing that library
because of it's very compelling public
interest to provide literature and free
access to information in a municipality
you could have an example though of um a
nonprofit that exists for some examples
might be like a nursing home that you
know there's been numerous um lawsuits
and rulings by the uh the the btla um
regarding you know the nonprofit status
and the you know the commercial
operations of some nonprofits that
provide a service and um whether or not
they should be tax Exempted in some ways
this would allow a local municipality to
say well there's clearly a lot of
commercial aspects to your nonprofit and
the charitable um services that you're
providing so would you be willing um
because of how large your infrastructure
is and you know how many people live
maybe at your physical plant uh to
provide some revenues to the property
tax space um in many of those
organizations they do Mr Dees your your
answer is going on and on I appreciate
your knowledge and your detail but try
to make it more concise because a lot of
words people start losing what you're
saying good I thank you thank you
additional
questions representative Elward thank
you Madame chairman Mr duche thank you
for taking my question um on line
15 um Roman
2 any city or town that adopts this
section shall adopt an ordinance or
bylaw so the
how does the town adopt this section and
doesn't the legislative body adopt or
pass
ordinances um it depends on the
ordinance so often time boards are
select and will adopt ordinances to
govern the entire uh community in this
case it's a um the legislative body is
voting to require its governing body to
adopt the ordinance or bylaw I would
agree that it would be better suited for
the bill to um to cite what governing
body um which is why you know I guess I
kind of left it out my initial testimony
but I meant to include it as to mention
that it's Boards of Selectmen or Boards
of assessors that would kind of oversee
um what what uh what kind of um how
they're assessing taxes in the community
and who's allowed to have exemptions or
um approval of like a um an appeal of an
abatement and things of that nature so
um I think it would serve the bill
better if the committee were to move
forward and recommend a to pass to
clarify that section but the intent of
that section is for whoever the
governing body is that oversees that
process to adopt a bylaw and ordinance
for how this would operate in their
municipality thank you further questions
representative
Gilman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question if there is a
court case that already established that
a nonprofit needs to pay for part of
what they do and and in this case it's
an educational institution that needs to
part pay taxes for any part that is not
aimed at
education would this as an enabling uh
Bill and
um Al also a um select board making a
regulatory or or
um what's the word I want um bylaw Etc
would would the bylaws and regul from
the select board override that court
case so if I'm understanding your
question correctly and please correct me
if I'm wrong um land or property that is
not being used for the charitable or the
nonprofit use that has to be based on
RSA 72 colon 23 which we'll have a
discussion on House Bill 147 I think
after this hearing or maybe two hearings
from now that land has to be assessed
and taxed because it's not being used
for a charitable or nonprofit profit to
my understanding the way we read the
bill is that this is land that's
currently under and being used by the
charitable or the nonprofit for its
stated use and this would if a local
governing body were to adopt the
provisions of this law require the
municipality to adopt bylaws and
ordinances to negotiate a 25% pilot for
those other lands that are covered under
the charitable or nonprofit use okay
thank
you additional questions
seeing none I appreciate your input
thank
you next the chair calls Mr Henry Vu
followed by Mr Ben Saul welcome to
Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair uh and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Henry veu and I'm here behalf
of the New Hampshire Alliance of
YMCAs I'm going to use 90 seconds give
the chair 90 seconds back um very
briefly um the wise Statewide fundraise
about $2 million annually to help uh
with scholarships for people in the
community that can't afford the services
that we provide so we send kids to
summer camp that otherwise couldn't go
uh we help provide child care uh
Wellness programs um and if we were
subject to this bill that would just
mean that's less U support that we can
provide uh for those people to engage in
those services so we oppose the
Bill thank you
questions seeing none
thanks chair recognizes Mr Ben Saul
followed by Mr Ben Bradley welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chair thank you committee
members my name is Ben Saul I live in
maram but I'm here representing my
employer Visions for Creative Housing
Solutions which provides supported
housing for 35 individuals in
Enfield uh Handover and Lebanon these
individuals have developmental
disabilities but many of them also has
have physical disabilities and uh are
medically complex we provide residential
support medical supervision support in
the community and supported housing and
the point that I wanted to make uh
that's relevant here is the narrowness
of the of the margins that organizations
like ours operate on so our sources of
income are the rent that our individuals
pay they're all under 30% Ami in other
words they're very low income they rely
on
SSI uh so we're getting rent payments
based on their SSI benefit we receive
funding from Medicaid to pay for the
services hour for hour that we provide
and then to cover the balance we fund
raise which is approximately 12% of our
operational spending so for
organizations like ours to impose uh
taxes in addition to um those that we're
already paying um is potentially
existential issue you know it's reduce
Services close or fundrais to uh ask
people to help us pay our taxes um in
terms of negotiating
with
municipalities small organizations like
ours you know I happen to be a lawyer we
so we have a lawyer but we're in the
minority we certainly don't have
lobbyists and so you know we're we're
not we're the weak ones when it comes to
if we're put in a position of having to
negotiate for our survival thank you
I'll take any
questions thank you
questions seeing none have a nice
afternoon thank you madam chair thank
you committee
members next the chair recognizes Mr Ben
Bradley followed by Mr Matt
Ley good morning and welcome to
Municipal and County government good
morning Madam chair thank you for the
opportunity to speak before the
committee my name is Ben Bradley I
represent um all 26 of New Hampshire's
Community Hospitals as well as all all
specialty hospitals in New Hampshire the
hospital Association is opposed to HB
625 we do have significant concerns
about the legislation and its impact on
nonprofits relationship with local
municipalities 22 of New Hampshire's 26
Community Hospitals are not profit and
exempt from property taxes under RSA
72 some nonprofit hospitals however have
made local arrangements to make payments
in Lee of taxes otherwise known as
Pilots these are decisions made at the
local level with thoughtful
consideration uh with local leaders uh
for the needs of the
municipality uh we are exempt these
nonprofit hospitals are exempt from
paying property taxes in return for the
charitable benefits they provide to
their communities and I've attached to
my testimony uh the 2024 Community
benefits report that was recently
published by the foundation for healthy
communities and the hospital Association
which outlines in more detail these
charitable contributions
we do work collabora collaboratively in
uh communities to assess and identify
the needs of the communities through
detailed Community Health needs
assessments these are required by the um
division of charitable trusts in the
Attorney General's office uh and we also
Implement uh create an implementation
plan to demonstrate how we intend to
address those Community Health
needs um in September
2024 uh the American Hospital
Association published an analysis that
showed the tax exempt hospitals deliver
10 times the federal tax exemption in
benefits to their
communities um you can see in the
community benefits assess uh Community
benefits reports that uh New Hampshire's
nonprofit Community Hospital has
provided over
$668 million in community benefits in
2022 uh we do provide for a number of um
jobs contributing billions of dollars to
our local economy in salaries and
benefits I've included a hospital fact
sheet on the economic contributions
these hospitals make um coupled Al
together uh primary and secondary
contrib job contributions amount to uh
43,000 jobs in New Hampshire uh and we
just believe that decisions about
whether a community and a nonprofit
hospital or other should enter into
pilot or local decisions and ones that
will be determined based on the local
community needs um decision makers and
and others um but there's there's as has
been mentioned before there's already an
ability to talk with local
municipalities and work through options
for how to establish pilots and as I
mentioned uh some of our nonprofit
members have already establish those um
I'm happy to take questions and answer
to any um comments that have already
been made
thank you
questions seeing none thanks thank
you the chair calls Mr Matt
Ley welcome to Municipal and County
government good morning thank you madam
chair uh for the record I'm Matt Ley I'm
the public policy director for the
Society of the protection of New
Hampshire Forest we are a nonprofit Land
Trust so we own
and conserve open space land um all over
New Hampshire um we oppose the bill I
would you know just make uh a couple
points about the forest Society the the
land we own we
actually are paying at the current use
rate so we we're not exempting the land
we own um we have another property up in
Bethlehem it's our uh Christmas tree
maple syrup operation um the land there
is in current use it the property has
several buildings which we have entered
into a payment and Le of taxes uh
arrangement with the town um but I'm
really here sort of talk less about the
for society and really as a the for
society's member you know uh role in the
nonprofit community and you've already
heard from a number of other
organizations about what they do and
their their services and I would you
know as the committee is considering
this bill the nonprofit Center published
back in 2019 this brief that kind of
outlines all the benefits and impact
that nonprofits in New Hampshire have so
again as you're considering this bill I
would definitely encourage you to to
look at that document it's on the
nonprofit Center's website but I'm happy
to take any questions
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
so my the last pin card that I have here
um I can't decipher the handwriting it's
a little bit fancy so I think it's um
something
wor welcome to miss to Municipal and
County government could you pronounce
your name yes my name is Maurice sble
Reese I was kind of close on the last
name thank you I first would like to
thank all of you for your time and
service to New Hampshire and ensuring
that we are the best place and P state
in this country to raise and live and
work so thank you for your service I am
Maurice wble I'm the CEO of the front
door agency located in Nash New
Hampshire our agency just recently
celebrated our 38th year providing a
holistic approach to break the cycle of
poverty by assisting families and IND
individuals to stabilize transform and
become empowered to ultimately achieve
self sustainable
Independence we offer three main
programs transformational housing for
single mothers with young children
permanent Supportive Housing and a
housing stability program today I'm here
to speak to you on opposition of House
Bill
625 this bill if passed would have a
significant consequence to this on the
steps the state has taken to expand
affordable and Workforce housing
the front door agency's transformational
housing program offers affordable
housing and extensive Supportive
Services to single mothers with young
children as they progress through the
Continuum of Care and become
self-sustaining members of our community
to do this we own four properties and
charge rental rates of less than $450 a
month so that our moms can create
stability for their families and attend
educational or job skill training
programs again with the ultimate goal of
achieving sustainable Independence
we currently take a loss on these
programs and fundraise accordingly
because we know that through our 36
years of History this program works in
addition we have a portfolio of three
properties offering permanent support of
affordable housing to those most
vulnerable providing 48 total units
rents charged are between $800 and
$1,100 a month for Studios to three
bedrooms and we offer Supportive
Services to the families residing there
as well with the average rental rate in
in NASA exceeding $2,300 for a
two-bedroom leving a property tax on
nonprofits offering the service would
only reduce the affordable housing
inventory in our
state in the last 6 months alone our
agency through our housing stability
program saw a
233% increase in the number of requests
for rental and utility
assistance the front door agency is a
business and we oppose this bill because
it represents an unfair tax on our
industry severe consequences for
municipalities in the state we fill a
gap that government does not at a time
where nonprofits are facing severe
challenges with higher demand potential
Cuts in federal funding this is not a
time to add an additional burden and
which will affect those we serve who
we're in business to serve thank
you thank you
questions seeing none thank you thank
you so that represented my last pink
card so I will ask is there anybody
present who wishes to speak on the bill
who has not yet had the opportunity to
do
so seeing none uh the chair now
recognizes representative Gilman to
report out the blue
sheets thank you madam chair uh on the
remote sign in we had 22 in support and
534 opposed
on today's blue sheet we have three four
and eight
against thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing
on House Bill 625
asked
about margin of operation that's
there I have not looked at it
at this time I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 147 relative to
clarifying tax exemptions for properties
used by religious educational and
charitable
organizations the chair recognizes
representative Mooney to introduce her
bill to us today and good morning and
welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you very much Madam
chair and good morning to you and good
morning to members of the House
Municipal and County government
committee for the record my name is
state representative Moren money I
represent the town of miramac which is
Hillsboro County District number 12 I'm
the prime sponsor and in support of
House Bill 147 an act relative to
clarifying tax exemptions for properties
used by religious
educational and charitable
organizations it's quite important Madam
chair that I give you a copy of my
testimony for the record but also for
every member of the committee and my
paint card on the back of my testimony I
find will be a very helpful
demonstration of the changes in bold and
strikeout that house bill 147 proceeds
to accomplish so at this point I'm going
to approach
you may proceed thank you House Bill 147
is a clarifying bill that provides an
explicit
definition for the word
appertaining it has been brought to my
attention that the term appertaining can
and has been interpreted in various ways
when it comes to determining lots and
buildings used for religious educational
and charitable purposes house spell 147
gives it a firm definition in fact just
as a a brief exercise eyes I Googled
quickly on a dictionary appertain the
word and it two definitions immediately
came up just as a demonstration of how
vague this term is and how easily it
could be interpreted in various ways the
first definition is quote relate to or
concern and the second definition is
quote be appropriate or
applicable so as you can see uh as a
standard there's a lot of room there for
interpretation House Bill 147 will make
it
clear House Bill 147 amends the sections
that refer to appertaining and instead
uses phrases such as quote on the same
lot which is on the bill page one line
22 and quote the entire building and lot
on which religious or in the instance of
Education are charitable activities are
taking place shall be exempt from
taxation under this section and that can
be found throughout the changes uh you
can look at House Bill 147 page 1 lines
25 to
27 and again uh you know OSS
Unfortunately they do a fantastic job
but unfortunately with this bill they
did not clearly highlight the changes
that would occur to current law in
section RSA
7273 so again I point out to you on the
back of my testimony you'll note that
only three
sections in RSA
7223 are amended and I very carefully
took it upon myself to make those
changes in bold and strike out on the
back of my testimony so you can see
exactly what it is you would be V voting
on these are important sections of Law
and it is critical that they be clear in
verbiage for the religious educational
and charitable organizations that use
them I ask that you recommend ought to
pass on House Bill 147 and I thank you
for your attention to this matter and
always for your service thank you madam
chair thank you representative Mooney
questions representative Gilman is
recognized for a question thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh I should have asked this
actually on the last bill but I'm going
to ask you too uh because of the um
definition change how does this apply to
museums and their
properties they're not educational or
they don't they're not
defined thank you for that question um
it's a good one I would say that
this bill and this section of law is
relevant to religious educational and
charitable
organizations so whether or not a
specific Museum would be classified as
perhaps educational or charitable in
that instance this would apply to them
but without that
classification uh I'm not sure what it
would be classified as but that's my
best take on your question sure
further questions representative majori
thank you madam chairwoman and thank you
representative for taking my question
and I certainly appreciate clarifying
language to clear things up which goes
to my question in line
25 for the purposes for the purposes for
which they were established couldn't
that
also be ambiguous or or or or or
interpreted in different ways so then
the second part of that is could that
phrase be
eliminated thank you for that question
uh I would start out by saying that's
current law that you quoted and my bill
uh intends to clarify and flesh out so
thus the next sentence is the clarifying
Factor there whether or not those words
are necessary any longer um I don't know
I don't have an opinion on that at this
point because my focus was adding the
next
sentence um and also my focus was to
keep the law intact as much as possible
with adding clarifying
words sure additional
questions seeing none thank
you the chair will call Father trainer
followed by Mr Jim MEA
good morning Father and welcome to
Municipal and County
government thank you madam chairwoman
appreciate it my name is Father Rory
trainer I serve as the associate pastor
at St Peter Parish in Auburn as well as
St John the Baptist Parish in Suncook on
behalf of the Roman Catholic dasis of
Manchester I come before you today uh to
support House Bill uh 147 in my time in
Ministry I've seen how our churches
operate on the front lines offering food
and financial and other assistance uh
most vulner to the most vulnerable in
our New Hampshire communities our
pastors collaborate with local officials
and others in the community to meet the
most basic human needs from feeding the
hungry clothing the naked and providing
shelter and care for the homeless and
while our local day-to-day interactions
are largely collaborative we have
experienced challenges in a number of
municipalities consistent with the
description found in the purpose in
findings of House Bill 147 I'm here just
to speak to one example in our Parish
where the wooded area of our Cemetery
that is preserved for the future use of
the cemetery has been subject to
taxation uh you'll find additional
examples experienced throughout the
dases in the written to testimony I will
present uh as well as information about
the time and expenses this has uh had on
our our communities the Catholic church
has and will continue to serve
individuals in need because we are deci
deciples of Jesus Christ but the
ambiguity of the existing law is posing
challenges to our ability to continue to
serve at the current level and a
decrease in the level of contribution
and services by houses of worship and
other organizations impacted by the
ambiguity in the current law undoubtedly
would increase pressure on local and
state governments to make up the Gap it
also causes the risk of uncertainty for
small organizations and locations such
as our Parish in sunuk uh for these
reasons we respectfully urge the
committee to recommend to uh pass House
Bill 147 uh I have here the um testimony
or rather a statement from the
chancellor of the dases and I'll read it
to you dear
Representatives as the chancellor of the
Roman Catholic dasis of Manchester and
on behalf of Bishop Peter labashi I
write to support House Bill 147 which
seeks to clarify tax exemptions for
properties used by religious educational
and charitable
organizations with churches schools and
cemeteries and municipalities from errel
to exor and from Hanover to Hampton our
Ministries have extensive experience
working with municipalities across the
granite state churches offer food and fi
financial and other assistance to those
in need in our local communities our
locations serve as polling places
pastors collaborate with local officials
and others in the community to meet the
most basic human needs from feeding the
hungry clothing the naked and providing
shelter and care for the homeless while
local day-to-day interactions are
largely collaborative ative we have
experienced challenges in a number of
municipalities consistent with the
descriptions found in purpose and
findings of House Bill 147 by way of
example the wooded land of cemeteries
preserved for future use has been
subject to taxation wooded areas of
church property have been subject to TA
taxation individual rooms of rectory of
of a rectory the living space for a
Catholic priests assigned to a church
have been questioned as to whether they
are directly used for religious purposes
documents requests from municipalities
in the last two years have been
extensive and specifically related to
the issues addressed in House Bill 147
by way of example after the dases filed
the timely form A9 a municipality Senter
notice that additional information was
needed including a quote further
description of the religious Services
unquote and Parish meetings in religious
education at a church and to indicate
how the open grassy portion of a
property is used and occupied for
religious purposes
unquote responses to these requests from
municipalities are timeconsuming and can
be expensive we believe the Catholic
church is the largest non-government
provider of charitable services in New
Hampshire the Catholic church has and
will continue to serve individuals in
need because we are Disciples of Jesus
Christ but the ambiguity of the existing
law is posing challenges to our ability
to continue to serve at the current
level and a decrease in the level of
contribution and services by houses of
worship and other organizations impacted
by the ambiguity of the current law
undoubtedly would increase pressure on
local and state governments to make up
the Gap how's of worship and charitable
organizations across the state provide
indispensable assistance to the elderly
ill poor and vulnerable in New Hampshire
the ambiguity in current law causes
expenses and uncertainty for those who
are exempt as well as for
municipalities for these we reasons we
respectfully urge the committee to
recommend a to pass House Bill 147 thank
you for your consideration of Our
Testimony and for your service to the
people of New Hampshire sincerely
Meredith P cook Esquire Chancellor
thank you Father trainer would you
happen to have copies of of that did yes
they were passed around well they should
have been okay
so questions for the
father seeing none thank
you next the chair calls Mr Jim mow
followed by m Gretchen
Wade well welcome back
again thank you madam chair and
committee members uh my name is Jim
misho Chief assessor for the town of
Hudson uh my comments here are intended
to be neither Pro nor con they really
talk about technical aspects of the bill
and my comments don't necessarily
reflect the views of the Hudson Board of
Selectmen they have not voted on a
position on this
bill uh much of the handout that I've
given you talk uh about nine pages or so
goes back and looks at the prior
legislative history of this
statute the general court in this
session has 10 plus bills that deal with
this statute many of them are today in
front of this committee there's one in
front of I don't know why house Ways and
Means and there's a two that we know of
at least in the Senate so there's a lot
of activity on this uh statutory area um
the arrival of these bills is primarily
Arisen due to a lot of expected reaction
from institutional stakeholders this
reaction is primarily based upon
municipality's legal compliance with
existing laws and
rules said compliance efforts directly
attributable to the board of tax and
land appeals btla decisions over the
last two to three years New Hampshire
Supreme Court decision as well as stated
direction from the assessing Standards
Board as well as that from the
Dr the gamut of the bill proposals bring
us back some 30 years to go when the
last significant changes to RSA 72 colon
23 rose from a very well represented
study commission that worked in
reconciling the then language of R
7223 the bill language some in House
Bill 147 actually represents a return to
how the language was at least in
material ways back some 30 years ago as
the bill history shows us the changes
from 30 years ago were intended to and I
quote from the house Journal close
loopholes and protect against abuse and
they were made after two-year effort
again from an Institutional tax
exemption study
committee the chapter law from 30 years
ago specifically brought into the law
the very words that this bill 1147 W
stricken quote and the lands are
pertaining to them owned used and
occupied directly so folks that were
here in these seats some three decades
ago spent two years and ended up adding
that language for the reasons as stated
in regards to House Bill 147 itself the
bill states in the purpose and findings
that the word directly is not used in
the utilized in the charitable portion
of RSA
72235 that's not an accurate reading of
the current law all of the
non-governmental owned property
educational religious charitable all use
the words directly in their
context I've attached a blended version
to my testimony of the current
applicable provisions of the RSA so one
can see where the changed language is
where it's stricken and where the
language is
added the bill language does present
some possible problematic scenarios so
an otherwise qualifying charitable
entity buys the ball of the Mall of New
Hampshire and uses some of it for
charitable purpose they according to the
tenants of this bill they could then
qualify for the rest of the building as
being exempt now that's obviously a
ridiculous example but if it can happen
because of the language then it could
happen further the Bill's language
brings up some contradictions you can't
have statutory language that reads own
used by owned used used and occupied as
criteria and then exempt the whole
building as if it's not applicable this
bill raises more questions than it does
solve neire New Hampshire municipalities
have numerous buildings that have a
terrible entity owning the entire
building and lot and they have split up
spaces some is used for charitable some
used for commercial commercial and they
pay a proportionate share in property
taxes for the non-exempt
use if the cited number of examples did
occur exactly as written and a
municipality's governing body is not
applying the laws correctly there
already exists multiple Avenues in
statute to address this alleged Arata
btla Superior Court the AG's office the
Dr can launch an inquiry Etc what we
don't want to do is dramatically change
the reference laws because there are
some possible harms existing in a
veritable ocean of compliance with the
Law's requirements by nominally tax
exempt entities and government officials
alike there are those that believe that
a lot of harm to all affected
stakeholders can that can take years and
dollars to fix can come from making rash
and abrupt changes to RSA
7223 and its related contingent laws as
is proposed in the 10 plus bills cited
so far for this legislative session this
might just be the time as it was 30
years ago for both the House and Senate
leaderships in bipartisan fashion to
establish a wellth thought-out study
commission with the most appropriate
stakehold as represented so to arrive at
the most just fair and equable
resolution to these issues thank
you thank you questions for Mr
Misha seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you the chair recognizes Miss Gretchen
Gretchen Wade followed by Mr Brody Dees
welcome to Municipal and County
government can you hear me okay okay
there we go um I would like to piggyback
off of what the prior speaker just said
um that there's been three decades that
have passed since this uh was last
researched and unfortunately there have
been three decades of litigation on
figuring out what exactly this ambiguous
statute is meant to say um my colleague
here attorney Michael Tierney is now in
the room will be able to provide more
further information on those specific
cases however I'm here to address and
support this bill because unfortunately
this language is not only ambiguous for
the individual property owner but is
also ambiguous for the town um and
whether or not the town has decided to
initiate litigation or the individual
who has the tax assessed against them
otherwise it is a cost um so whether or
not as another prior speaker had
mentioned unburied person's area of a
cemetery is taxed differently
um where obviously individuals have not
died but then will eventually be buried
um but the town then also has unburied
persons area in their cemetery and are
not taxed on that um so looking through
the entire statute of 7223
municipalities charitable organizations
educational organizations and religious
organizations all have to go through a
little bit of a different test and this
bill would put everyone on the same
playing field so whether or not the town
has a cemetery where there are unburied
persons where there's open ground for
future individuals and a religious
organization that has a cemetery where
there is ground where there are unburied
individuals this would put them on the
same playing field um so to the extent
that the committee has any questions I
would ask you to support this Bill thank
you thank you
questions seeing none thank you thank
you the chair calls Mr bro Dees followed
by representative Julie
miles thank you to the committee and um
my name for the record is Brody desesa
represent an Amire Municipal Association
I'll be brief because uh most of most of
the points that I were going to make
were made by Mr misho of Hudson um I do
just want to flag um I do want to flag
two things one is um a concern in
section three of the bill um the last
sentence uh lines 25 26 and 27 um where
it states the entire building and laot
on which religious activities are taking
place shall be exempt from taxation
under this section um we find it that
some of our accessors it'll be kind of
confusing because if you have a building
and you have a wedding there for example
um that's a religious activity and does
all of a sudden do wedding venues be
considered um could they apply if they
were especially if they were a nonprofit
could would their entire you know maybe
some of the commercial aspects of what
they're doing would that be tax exempt
so that was one thing where we found
that could be ambiguous and there
obviously are nonprofit or for example
churches where they do wedding
ceremonies and we understand why they're
tax ex them because they're religious
organization but we found that that
could add some additional ambiguity for
when and when when and when not a um
organization that's hosting a religious
activity whether or not they tax exempt
um another thing that we really want to
flag is um by allowing all the property
that um the you know the nonprofit has a
has a um buildings or they're utilizing
for their specific charitable or
nonprofit use um by allowing the entire
lot to be included you could
theoretically have you know a church
might only have its church and its
parking lot and the things you know they
where they do different activities for
religious activities or not just a
church but any house of worship on only
an acre but they may own up to 25 acres
and um as long as the areas of the lot
that aren't being used for any religious
or charitable or um nonprofit usage that
is subject to taxation Our concern is in
some instances and in some
municipalities you would see a massive
burden shift from these organizations
that are paying taxes on land that they
own that aren't being used at all for
any charitable nonprofit or religious
use and instead um that land would all
of a sudden become exempt and you would
be shifting it to all the other property
taxpayers and um in the municipality so
any other business Commercial
institution or uh residential homeowners
so that's our biggest concern with the
bill is that could see in many instances
um a tax burden shift for land that
isn't being actively used by the
nonprofit charitable organization or
house of worship religious organization
for any of their stated purpose um of
their organization and fulfilling their
mission their goals or religious
Doctrine and Creed and so with that I'll
yield to any questions but I think Mr
Misha's testimony was pretty
comprehensive and helping uh point out
some of the larger assessing
issues thank thank you for your
testimony
questions seeing none thanks thank
you next the chair recognizes
representative miles welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chairwoman thank you members
of the committee my name is
representative Julie miles and I
represent the town of marac I am a
co-sponsor on this bill and I'm here
today to voice my support for House Bill
147 uh because it is matter M of
fairness Clarity and good governance for
municipalities too often towns are left
dealing uh dealing with unclear or un
inconsistent policies that create
confusion unnecessary disputes and
financial strain this bill helps ensure
that local governments are not put in a
position where they have to guess at how
certain properties should be taxed or
face legal battles over unclear
exemptions it provides much needed
consistency and predictability with
which is exactly what M municipalities
and their residents need without this
bill we could see towns caught in costly
legal challenges local organ
organizations facing unexpected tax
burdens and communities losing out on
services that these organizations
provide uncertainty and tax policy can
divide communities and strain
relationships between municipalities and
the people they serve House Bill 147 the
goal is about keeping things fair and
clear for everyone involved it ensures
municipalities can focus on governing
not litigating and that organizations
doing important work in our communities
are treated consistently I urge the
committee to support House Bill 147 and
help us avoid unnecessary conflicts
hurting both towns and
taxpayers thank
you take any questions but thank you
representative miles questions for the
representative seeing none oh
representative
grundt thank you madam chairwoman um so
just a clarification so we heard earlier
that there was a concern about gambling
charitable organizations being part of a
building that's much larger than itself
can you comment as to how you feel that
fits into this bill I think simple
Amendment with a clarifying statement
regarding that would be suitable
further questions seeing none thank you
you so the final and last pink card that
I have is Mr Michael
Tierney that's attorney tney correct
welcome to Municipal and County
government yes
thank thank you thank you for having me
Michael Cherney I am an attorney in
Manchester I've represented uh dozens of
entities both Municipal entities as well
as religious entities as well as
charitable entities as well as
educational entities all four different
categories in different cases over the
years and while this statute hasn't
changed in 30 years the way in which it
has been interpreted has changed in the
last 2 years you have an increase of
assessors who are looking and trying to
find Little Bits that they can say are
not being used for for religious or
educational purposes and if you look at
the statute the charitable tax exemption
currently doesn't have the language of a
pertinent there to if anyone can tell me
what the limits of a pertinent there to
is I would love to hear it um there's no
case law that has determined what a
pertinent there to is um but it has been
used by some towns and some assessors
but not others okay in order to try to
find that there's some lands um that
should be taxable and not tax exempt
what type of lands am I talking about
well I'm thinking about one particular
school that's run by a religious order
okay so they're entitled to a religious
tax exemption and they have about 30
acres and a 50 foot wide um parcel of
woods around the outside of their school
a a wooded buffer um and the town after
for 25 years I think giving them a
complete tax exemption okay has now
determined that that wooded
buffer is not pertinent there to the
school buildings therefore it is a
taxable property that's not just one
town we have dozens of towns all across
the state okay who are looking at
Aerials are making those determinations
and frankly it wastes a lot of time on
behalf of the towns as well as on behalf
of the churches and the educational
institutions to be saying oh hold on a
second it's not a 50ft wide buffer it's
a 60ft wide buffer or you know this
particular year it's a 55 foot buffer
and the next year it's a 45t buffer
we're not talking about you know a large
number of dollars here um the case I'm
talking about is about a $400 tax bill
for that 50 foot wide buffer it's not
going to break the bank um but it is
going to be fair to treat that religious
run School the same as any charitable
entity you don't see in the charitable
part that pertinent there too you don't
see for the public school that pertinent
there too so regardless of the point of
the tax exemption okay let's just make
them all the same make them all equal
okay so that they can be fairly and
equally
applied I have written testimony I'd be
happy to pass it around um I've done
these cases um on all four sides um and
so I've seen it from all different
angles I'd be happy to answer any
question questions the committee
has questions for attorney Tierney the
chair recognizes representative majority
for a question thank you madam
chairwoman and thank you for taking my
question which will be a repeat that I
that I asked the prime sponsor I'm just
really curious about the language for
the purpose which they were
established um and again not having the
Bold I I think the prime sponsor said
that's existing language but I'm just
trying to figure out if that then is
left to interpretation and maybe we
should if we're trying to tighten the
bolts down on this if maybe that we
should consider striking that language
what do you think in your experience so
that's existing language it's existing
language that I haven't really seen as a
a particular issue when you have an
entity that is exempt that rents out to
a for profit entity okay that is
something that for a religious or
educational entity makes that property
tax uh taxable it's taxable property but
for a charitable entity you can still
hold on to your tax exemption as long as
that charitable entity is using the rent
from the for-profit rent for its
charitable
purposes further
questions seeing none thank
you so at this time I will ask is there
anyone present who wishes to speak to
this bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none the
chair recognizes representative Gilman
to report out the blue
sheets thank you madam chair on the
remote uh sign in we had uh eight in
support and 10 opposed and one
neutral on today's blue sheet that's
signed in we have one
neutral uh
five in support and one uh
opposed thank you representative Gilman
and with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill
147 so at at this time I'd like to point
out that we are slightly behind schedule
House Bill 426 was scheduled to begin at
11:30 it is now slightly before noon and
what I will do is we will push through
the hearing on this bill and then when
that is done we will take a lunch break
and be back here at 1:00 to resume
public
hearings when the clerk is set up I will
open the public
hearing at this time the chair opens the
public hearing on House Bill 426
relative to property tax tax exemptions
for charitable organizations for the
prior tax
year the chair recognizes representative
McDonald to introduce the Bill thank you
uh thank you chair power I'm
representative John T McDonald I
represent C district 6 which is the fine
people of wolf B tuen bro want to thank
you for the opportunity to uh present
this bill and also the proposed uh
amendment number 20
25-14 1H I believe I held I had handed
those out a couple of days
ago this bill and the amendment will
help a very important group within our
state those being the hundreds of
nonprofit profs that are located
throughout our our state and communities
nonprofits provide the educational
Health and Social Services that our
Citizens need want and deserve
nonprofits fill the void which our local
M municipalities and the state cannot
provide for I'm not going to name all
the nonprofits that serve our
communities and state I'm sure after
sitting here for the past couple of
hours you've got a good idea of the
number local nonprofits help make our
community Stronger by the participation
of hundreds of volunteers the volunteers
experience Fellowship companionship
social interaction and the most
important feelings of contributing to a
goal and the accomplishments of the
nonprofit last session I introduced a
bill that would allow the board of
Selectmen to ensure that they could
accept late filings from nonprofits
based on accident mistake or Misfortune
this bill was passed by the New
Hampshire house senate and eventually
signed into law by the governor with an
effective date of April of
2025 and that's for reference that's RSA
72 colon 23
V1 prior to the passing of that bill I
was unaware of any accepted reason a
nonprofit give to PR prevent the late
filing P penalty causing the nonprofit
to pay their full tax bill for example
prior to this uh legislation being
passed a nonprofit would go to a post
office put it in the mail on say on
Wednesday or Thursday asked for one day
delivery on say around May 29th uh the
mail goes out it's on a weekend so now
the town doesn't go to the mailbox until
June 2nd they open up the letter and it
could be stamped June 2nd so effectively
it's late and they have to pay the taxes
the uh they have no opportunity to come
in and say hey look at I've got my
receipt here for one day delivery it
went to the mailbox and they didn't pick
it up till the following
Monday uh this this bill should be
considered a bridge for nonprofits who
were required to file before June 1st
2024 and April
2025 and were laid in
filing this bill will allow nonprofits
the opportunity to justify the lateness
being due to accident mistake and
Misfortune before the elected Board of
Selectmen to ask for an adjustment on
the property taxes and if denied they
may then appeal to the superior court or
the Bureau of Land and taxes
I hope you view this spill as a common
sense and reasonable and will allow our
nonprofits not to be hurt and give them
the opportunity to appear before their
board explain where the taxes uh the
proper paperwork was late thank
you thank you representative McDonald
questions representative
Elward thank you Madame chairman thank
you representative McDonald for taking
my
question um in line five it cites
accident mistake or Misfortune as a good
cause for
[Music]
um not filing on time could you tell me
that in your hypothetical male situation
would that be an accident mistake or
Misfortune
situation I would go with The
Misfortune uh I know I've got Christmas
cards that are stamped December 18th and
I've got them December 30th in the mail
so don't have a lot of faith in the male
service thank
you further
questions representative Walker root
cause of the original
problem Mike microphone the root cause
of the original problem isn't that
multiple years between their filings
it's not a it's not
a yearly filing for this right it's it's
basically kind of confusing because they
have to file one set of paperwork on the
in April and then another set of
paperwork in the June and some people
you know due to whatever uh didn't get
filed in in June and I think there was a
supremor court case uh that said there's
no reason that it can be late in the law
so that's why I put in this accident
Misfortune uh part of the law itself
okay thank you yeah additional
questions representative
France thank you madam chair thank you
um is there a particular time limit for
the forms to be late I mean like what if
they're like six months late or
something like that that would be
something that the board of selectman
would have to address whether there was
no reason for them to be late then they
could be you know taken off the
nonprofit list as far as taxes go all
this bill does is
just brings back the date of from April
of 2025 back to when June 1st of 2024
those groups in between that may be late
and that'll be a call by the board of
Selectmen and if they're not happy with
that they can appeal to Superior Court
or the Bureau of Land
appeals thank you thank you for the
question further questions seeing none
thank you thank you madam chair
next the chair recognizes Mr Andy moo
followed by Mr Jim
Misha welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chairman and
members of the committee um I'm going to
give you an example of how this goes
wrong my name is Andy moo and I'm the
chairman of the board of the right
Museum in wolfboro New Hampshire it's a
we've been a nonprofit organization for
30 years with property and wolfboro and
as a result we're a nonprofit that has
real estate presence we have to file an
A9 and a12 every year and one is due in
April and one is due in June until a
year ago when HB 11055 was passed and
amended RSA 7223 there was no provision
at all for a late filing due to accident
mistake or Misfortune the museum is a is
a small organization whose mission is to
provide a vivid perspective on the
profound and enduring impact of the
World War II experience on American
society the museum has three full-time
staff and several part-time seasonal
staff the museum filed this a12
correctly for many years the Museum's
June 24 filing was late due to a serious
family medical issue experienced by the
staff person responsible for that filing
and was exacerbated by an illness of one
of the seasonal workers and that person
was covering the front desk for
admissions in addition to doing
everything else they were doing as it
has for several years the filing only
contained a listing of board members
since our final financial statements
were not available by the due date we
file an extension for our tax return and
each year and the financials were
provided later in the year prior to the
extension date during our appeal to the
town the board the wolfboro board of
selectman was very sympathetic to our
situation since we're an economic driver
in the community we attract over 18,000
people to the town each year who spend
money on hotels and meals and retail
stores however since the effective date
of the legislation HP 1055 that
representative McDonald talked about was
April 1st 2025 the town attorney did not
did not support the board's
recommendation to grant us an exemption
as a result the museum lost its tax
exempt status for a year at a cost of
over $50,000 in real estate taxes this
this represents more than 10% of our
Revenue um given the circumstances
described above this seems to be a very
severe penalty for a late administrative
filing so as a result we support House
Bill
426 thank you thank you questions
seeing none
thanks the chair now calls Mr Jim
Misha good afternoon thank you madam
chair and committee members for the
record Jim misho Chief assessor for the
town of Hudson I come before you I was
releas some questions about this bill uh
I first want to point out I'm I'm not an
attorney um but my written testimony uh
speaks to a possible unconstitutional
provision with this bill the Hampshire
Constitution part one article 23
retrospective law is prohibited
retrospective laws are highly injurious
suppressive and unjust no such laws
therefore should be made either for the
decision of civil causes or the
punishment of
offenses the applicable law was
effective for April 1
2025 it was not applicable for April 1
2024 I don't know that a law can reach
backwards to unspell milk I think the
Constitution says you can't further
point out another issue there are
communities where the taxpayer the The
Entity has appealed to the btla btla has
agreed with the law there is no
exception for April 1 2024 and the late
filing of the a12 so the btla has
supported the law the btla has supported
the uh Municipal assessing official
decision and now what decision's been
made correct you can't go backwards so
you pass this law you have communities
that have to make a choice do they fall
a foul of the btla judicial judicial
decision or do they follow this law that
really presents a
conundrum
additionally it's like you're accepting
the
application late that you have no
provision
for but even if you had a provision for
it you can't accept that form after the
local tax rate has been set that's set
out in law well all the tax rates for
2024 for almost all the communities in
the state has already been set so how
can you accept something late for which
the tax rate's already been set it
presents a
problem it also presents a problem about
preceden what other bills are we going
to see they're going to retrospectively
change I don't know a zba appeal
deadline a planning board appeal
deadline you can see where this might
become a unwise public policy
decision lastly the bill appears to try
to create a legislatively derived
specific reason property owner missing
deadline under the good cause provisions
of RSA
7616 good cause is a recognized legal
term that is used in this and other New
Hampshire statutes judicial system has
enumerated in case law a very few four
limited reasons for abatements and they
are on the btla municipal abatement
application none of them say missed the
deadline so I'm going to rest my
testimony uh the written testimony goes
into a little bit more detail and I'll
take any
questions thank you
questions seeing none thank you thank
you and the last pink card that I have
is Mr Salvatore
prio welcome to Municipal and County
government good good afternoon Madam
chair and everybody uh thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony and
support of House Bill 426 which would
allow nonprofit organizations to receive
property tax exemptions retroactively my
name is Salvatore prio I'm the executive
director of the capital Center for the
Arts a nonprofit Performing Arts venue
located here in conquer additionally I
currently serve on New Hampshire Center
for nonprofits policy committee as one
of the state's largest cultural
institutions the CCA has been a
Cornerstone of New Hampshire's creative
economy for over 30 years hosting
thousands of performances educational
programs and community events annually
our mission is to not only entertain but
to enrich lives of our communities
through the Arts education and cultural
experiences last year alone we welcomed
over a 100,000 patrons to the community
of conquered and our story is just one
of hundreds across every town and city
in the state much like prior testimony
we heard today Capital Center for the
Arts is a living example of how this
bill can affect an
organization to date we've filed our
property tax exemption forms on time and
without issue for 30 years in a row in
2024 we filed part one of the exemption
on time the second part was filed no
more than 5 days late due to extenuating
and reasonable circumstances that were
beyond our control despite our best
attempts to settle this matter locally
we have not been successful and we are
now appealing our case before Superior
Court for a late property tax file fing
and while I can understand inhere to the
rules and regulations the strict and
non-flexible deadline can prove to be
destructive for organizations like ours
there was no fine there's no
consideration for it just a tax bill for
the total value of our properties which
for this year will be
$150,000 I would certainly hope that we
can appreciate the challenges that an
unexpected $150,000 bill would be to any
organization the results of these
challenges will divert funds away from
are essential programming educational
initiatives and Community uh
Partnerships directly impacting our
ability to serve the people of New
Hampshire allowing retroactive property
tax exemptions under
hb426 would provide Flex uh Financial
flexibility to nonprofit organizations
and recognize the vital role we play in
our communities this legislation would
not only honor the intent of the current
laws governing nonprofit exemptions but
would also align with New Hampshire's
commitment to fostering a driving
nonprofit sector I would say too that as
of 2022 arts and culture have provided
$3.4 billion of economic activity for
the state and which by the way is tied
with the construction industry arts and
culture provide over 21,000 jobs for New
Hampshire and we seek a sensible policy
for an industry that is so vital to our
community on behalf of the CCA and the
New Hampshire Center for nonprofits and
the communities we serve I urge you to
support
hb426 and Ensure that nonprofits across
our state can dedicate their resources
to the mission that make New Hampshire a
vibrant vibrant and compassionate place
to live thank you for consideration and
I'm open to any
questions thank you and
questions seeing none okay thank
you so that was my last pink card and I
will ask is there anyone present who
wishes to speak to this bill who has not
yet had the opportunity to do so seeing
none the chair will recognize
representative Gilman to report out the
blue
sheet thank you madam chair on the
remote signin we had five in support and
four opposed one neutral and on today's
blue sheet we have one neutral and two
in
support thank you representative Gilman
and with that I will close the public
hearing on House Bill 426
so at this time we have um recovered
from our schedule it is now quar aast 12
and we will take lunch and be back here
at 1 to resume our public
hearings
e
e e
good afternoon the time is a little past
1:00 and we will resume our public
hearings at this time I would like to
open the public hearing for House Bill
617 relative to the homestead
right we have with us this afternoon
representative Lichfield to introduce
the legislation to us today welcome to
ipal and County government thank you
madam chair and thank you members of the
committee my name is Melissa Lichfield
and I represent the towns of Brentwood
Danville and Fremont today I'm here
bringing this bill forward the homestead
right it was initially brought to me
actually by a
constituent in November um followed up
by an attorney in town who had also
stated that there was a real need for
this the gist of it is this is a law
that is actually already on the books
um and simply just simply states that if
for any reason you've gone into debt or
you've been sued right now you're
covered up to
$120,000 of your home so you wouldn't
lose the roof over your head if you're
married that doubles the problem is that
this law hasn't kept up with the market
value of the homes so I in doing my
research what I had done is I looked New
Hampshire's wul low at 120,000 I
researched all 50 states um some states
for example Florida the value of the
home is
unlimited the average home in New
Hampshire is about median home is about
$480,000 I had actually put in this bill
up to a million dollar um I know that I
need to put an amendment in I know the
committee owns this but if you would
allow me to put an amendment originally
this bill was also supposed to mention
trusts and I didn't realize I apologize
until just a few minutes ago that trusts
are not included in here um so at that
point in time if you would prefer that
the amount be amended somewhere between
500,000 and a million I understand I did
not double it in the case of if you're
married because in my opinion the cost
of a house is the cost of a house it
doesn't really matter whether or not you
are
married
um I also tried to put some bumpers into
this law so for
example obviously if you have a mortgage
or if you have a home equity um they can
still seize your home okay if there are
outstanding loans let's say for um condo
fees or HOA fees they can still take
your
home the gist of it is just for to
protect you if let's say there is a
lawsuit like a car accident or something
along those lines where they're going
after the insurance money but these days
they don't feel as though the insurance
money is enough so they're going after
the roof over your head that's all my
goal in this is just to protect the roof
over your
head I also looked up and under Chapter
7 bankruptcy in the United States um if
you meet certain requirements your home
is also protected there as well you're
up to date on your mortgage payments um
you're able to continue with your future
payments and um it's it also me a
homestead exemption it says protect your
home equity from creditors through a
homestead
exemption um I just if I may really
quickly I had an expert witness that was
supposed to be here which was an
attorney in our town and unfortunately
he was unable to make it today so I just
wanted to share with you very briefly uh
members of the committee I am providing
this testimony and support of increasing
the homestead exemption as the prices of
homes have exponentially increased the
homestead exemption has not
correspondingly kept up thus exposing
homeowners to judgment creditors it has
been my experience that over the past 5
years the growth of certain plaintiff's
law firms often based outside of New
Hampshire that can often be found on
billboards or television ads has also
resulted in claims and lawsuits that
threaten homeowners in the past those
representing Plaines would be satisfied
with going after insurance and would not
seek to attach and go after someone's
home to satisfy their claim as
homeowners have seen and acceleration in
their home values this has led to
certain firms using this Equity as a way
to leverage greater monetary Awards the
following are a couple of examples of
this from my civil defense law practice
I had a recent case involving a
collision between two skiers on the
slopes objectively this was not a
situation involving Reckless conduct but
rather was an accident between two
individuals whose path intersected
resulting in a collision unfortunately
one of the skiers was hurt and as often
happens a lawsuit followed in this case
the person was sued had a home and
because of the threat that this home
would be sold to pay off for the
Judgment a greater settlement was
leveraged by the plaintiff's attorney um
and then it just it goes on to mention
how the homeowner had an elderly and Ill
parent who he needed to take care of
leading to an unenviable situation um so
the person actually settled for more so
they wouldn't go after their home he
said while I support the Bill's increase
to 1 million I do think that an amount
between 500,000 to 1 million would be
reasonable given that home ownership is
something that everyone works and
strives towards the equity of this one
asset deserves greater protection in New
Hampshire um and then also I have
submitted from the constituent a letter
too that you can look at um in your free
time to take a look at and I think
that's it I also just wanted to let you
know the only reason why I don't have um
a plethora of Co co-sponsors on here
simply I put the bill in right after the
election we had that tight squeeze with
OSS and there was a I think we all kind
of felt the growing pains with OLS this
time around so that's simply all it was
it was just didn't have a
chance thank you representative
Lichfield and you open for questions yes
questions for the prime
sponsor oh representative
majori thank you chairwoman and thank
you for taking what I hope is a really
easy question why the effective date a
year out 26 any any real reason for that
no okay I just didn't know if there was
any any any any provision of law which
said we need to wait another year no in
a in a perfect world honestly I would
love to make it effective in 60 days but
I was just trying to give time for
everybody to get the laws changed and
updated that's all thank you further
questions
seeing none thank
you next the chair calls
representative
gearon welcome to Municipal and County
government thank you madam chair
honorable members of the committee for
record representative Henry gas and
Hillsboro 29th
so I am always in support of anything
that protects our taxpayers our
homeowners and our and our citizens and
this does exactly that um I actually for
what it's worth I would not change the
dollar amount from a million dollars
simply because with 480 being the mean
household many of us have more invested
in our property and that's the one thing
that we as civilians should be able to
own as a piece of
property um I like the Protections in
this because you do see a lot of
frivolous litigation one thing that I
would like to see you know and um The
Honorable sponsor of this suggested that
there would be an amendment going in to
expand it to um Family trusts as well
and I think that's very important uh one
other thing I would like to see possibly
removed from this is line 27 domestic
support obligations because I have seen
frivolous lawsuits for alimon and child
support cost foreclosures of houses and
you know while I do believe that is an
obligation to take care of kids I do I
also believe that frivolous litigation
to go after somebody's home is exactly
that it's frivolous and it causes
homelessness which will impact their
ability to support their child um or
support that alimony so I would like to
see if that line could be stricken other
than that this seems to be a very
necessary piece of legislation to
protect homeowners from frivolous
lawsuits and i would support
it thank you
questions seeing none thank you
next the chair recognizes representative
McFarland good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County
government good afternoon and uh thank
you for your time representative
McFarland from Orange representing
Grafton
18 I uh first of all if you bear with me
just want to give a a quick disclaimer
this testimony represents My Views and
the views and interests of my
constituents in graft and 18 and my
testimony is not made on behalf of any
private employer nor should it be
constru to represent the views of any of
my employers I'm here to speak in
support of uh House Bill
617 I think that uh you've already heard
most of the arguments that I could make
and I do believe that the adjustment in
the value here is overdue and well
warranted um and I think it protects
uh the interests of our our constituents
and achieves a balance between the
ability of creditors to uh obtain the
the uh the the repayments that they are
due uh the language in the bill I've
heard some people comment on it and I
have observed that that language is not
in fact uh does not in fact act in the
way that some have interpreted to act uh
it it strikes a very good balance I
think and has Provisions in there that
would not result in the parade of
horribles that uh I think some of you
may have heard nevertheless um uh I
think the other arguments as I said have
already been made so I yield to any
questions there may
be thank you
questions seeing none thanks thank
you and the last pink card that I have
is Mr Charlie Russell attorney Russell
welcome to Municipal and County
government uh Madam
chair uh members of the committee I'm
Attorney Charles Russell I've been
practicing law U probably no more than
three blocks from the state house since
the 70s I wanted to share my experience
uh way back it was 30,000 then it went
to 50 And1 120 where it stands now that
was the amount certainly it needs
adjustment for that reason um uh I also
speak because I've done bankruptcies
utilize the homestead exemption but
there was a case that came down in the
New Hampshire Supreme Court in um uh
August of uh 2023 the Brady versus susky
case where they basically said um a
spouse if her name or his or her name
was not on the deed could not claim the
homestead right and so that a um a
couple that went bankrupt was only
because she wasn't on the deed was only
able to claim it once and uh that
decision uh spoke to whether there need
to be legislative changes or not um and
I would suggest there is and I think
what happened is there was the homestead
exemption and generally the homestead
exemption goes way back to the 1800s
early 1900s where the husband would be
on the deed the wife wouldn't be there
the husband died you let the Widow stay
in the house for the remainder of her
life
then uh probably in the 80s they put
something in there about manufactured
housing and and I think that led to the
confusion with the Supreme Court making
the decision that it did I would suggest
that you split out any provision
pertaining to manufactured housing from
including it from non or general
residential uh property um because I
think that was the cause of the
confusion um looking down at the bill I
would suggest in bankruptcy if somebody
makes a claim of a home homestead
exemption and then they subsequently
sell the property that homestead
exemption extends onto the money that
are the proceeds here the treatment in
this bill was you give somebody six
months to reinvest that money I would
suggest given the current difficulties
in finding houses to to uh to buy you
may want to make that 12 months as
opposed to six months and and take that
that is in uh section uh section two um
further down I would indicate uh the
current language says the homestead
exemption homestead exemption doesn't
apply in the collection of taxes I would
suggest you be more specific I believe
that should apply to what's called
property taxes and not taxes from some
other source like I know in bankruptcy
federal income taxes are pretty much
treated like any other uh like any other
uh uh creditor bills um as to uh medical
debt um I would suggest that's an
approach riate uh uh situation I'd also
say there's a provision that talks about
basically when you get a mortgage you
don't get the mortgage unless you wave
your homestead right so that basically
the mortgage would take first POS uh
position so when it uses a language
which is made a charge if the homestead
right has been waved in the mortgage
that language would clear it up I've
also had experience on the sheriff sale
Provisions in the language there I've
actually used use that in a case
probably in the last 10 years and
basically that reflects a policy that um
a person's Homestead right takes
precedent you over somebody's bills and
you can't out somebody in an ERA with a
lot of homelessness and everything else
you want to make sure the homestead
right takes precedent over a creditor
Bill coming in a lot of it is credit
card debt and other things that I've
seen in bankruptcies and most of those
debts including medical debts are
discharged in bankruptcy which is a
federal proceeding but uh other
otherwise um for those comments um I
think it's a a pretty good bill uh in
law school I learned right so you're not
misunderstood so where you have a charge
uh prop taxes are exempt you should be
putting in their real estate or property
taxes so I'll take any
questions questions the chair recognizes
representative Elward thank you madam
chair chman and thank you sir for your
testimony what line are you talking
about that needs to have
property uh delineated property there is
a looks like in section
three um no I'm sorry section
two line
uh the the homestead right does not
cancel or raise any debts the home dead
right is exempt from attachment during
its
continuance for except for the following
ta things and then it so I think that's
two Roman numeral one the in the
collection of taxes I would add in the
collection of property taxes and then
there's a further provision that um I
was involved in the case on homeowner
associations that the result of that
case resulted in the condo associations
coming in and saying uh condo fees
that's further down so
otherwise I mean despite all my comments
I think it's a Well drafted bill with
some of the comments there it protects
people whether that number is
500,000 certainly it needs to at least
go to that if not a million I would also
say um you you asked about this we spoke
earlier that the homestead right can be
claimed whether or not The spouse's name
is on the deed I think that's what
happened in the bankruptcy case that
went to the Supreme Court the Brady case
so so basically uh you know and and that
comes up
one somebody buys a house gets married
later it's a second to third marriage
the wife's name or the husband's name
may not end up on the deed but if
they're living there and you have that
provision there they have to have lived
there for the last 12 months I'm sorry
to be too long go ahead followup
yes so would that protection carry over
to
a non-spouse
partner
um You probably all know more than about
civil unions and things like that
um I think the trust needs to be in
there but uh you probably ought to have
some language in there I mean if if
if same gender people marry I think they
refer to each other as husband and wife
and spouse
so it may go to that definition to the
extent it applies to civil unions if in
fact that has been um legally set up so
good point loophole that needs to be
covered thank you sir anything further
additional
questions seeing none appreciate your
time thank
you so at this time the chair recognizes
representative Gilman to report out on
the blue sheets for House Bill
617 thank you madam chair in today's uh
remote testimony there were four in
support and six opposed and on today's
blue sheet there was
nothing thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
617 and at this time we are ahead of
schedule so we need to wait until
1:30
e
e e
the time is now 1:30 and I will open the
public hearing on House Bill
425 allowing tax exempt entities to keep
their tax exempt status while renting
facilities or property to entities that
share their
and with us here today we have
representative Pearson to introduce the
bill to the committee welcome to
Municipal and County government thank
you madam chairwoman for the record my
name is Mark Pearson I'm in my ninth
year in the House of Representatives
some of that's Joe guth's
fault I chair children and family law
committee I also chair the DHHS
oversight committee this bill and the
one immediately following it have the
same backstory so allow me to give you
uh an informal rendering of that story
for decades in fact for centuries the
towns in New Hampshire had a wonderful
working relationship with the nonprofits
some of those were churches some of
those were fraternal
organizations but what the those groups
did was provide a lot of help and
assistance to the individuals in the
town as a result the relationship with
the town was
and some of this is
constitutional uh they would not be
taxed on their
properties this was mostly
informal in many cases the town fathers
they were just fathers back then later
fathers and mothers and the people in
the organizations that often served for
Generations it was just the way things
were
done unfortunately there was a court
case a few years back where an
charitable organization asserted some
things that seemed to go outside the
normal way of doing things they had
numbers of properties and they wanted
tax exemption for all of them this led
to a court case the church as it turned
out lost the court case and as a pastor
let me just say I think the church
should have lost that court case and
that let loose a an idea of gee what are
we doing in our town you know it's been
a quote gentleman's agreement for all
these decades and centuries what are we
doing here a company stepped forward and
said that that'd helped the towns figure
out who had tax exempt status who didn't
who should who shouldn't what the rules
might be and it led to a lot of chaos I
wound up getting a tax bill for
$88,000 for my
church and really folks now the folks in
Kingston New Hampshire are wonderful but
they didn't know what to do this had
never come up before suddenly an
organization told this is what we think
you could do it took a little while to
straighten this out and we got a refund
but numbers of town officials and
numbers of organizations churches
fraternal organizations and soone said
I'm afraid some of this stuff needs to
be codified now for too long it's been a
working agreement but now I think we've
got to get it in law so they approached
me they said would I do something about
it and I tried to research it I tried to
come up with something that was
fair this first bill before you has
mostly to do with church properties for
its clergy members there's a few other
things in there but this is the main
purpose of this bill it has been
adjudicated all the way up to the
Supreme Court that a churches call it a
rectory a mans a parsonage it's the
clergy members home is an extension of
the church and therefore is not real
estate tax
taxable and that worked well most clergy
members lived right next to their
church and so that's obvious that
building is next to the big tall
building but what started happening
about 50 or 60 years ago is in many
cases these downtown churches
neighborhoods were changing and the
clergy memb said I'm not so sure I want
to raise my family right downtown I'd
rather be out in the suburbs with most
of my members in addition clergy we
starting to say wait a minute I've just
turned 70 I'm retiring I have no equity
in a house because the house has always
been provided for me so that's when
something called a housing allowance was
developed and again this passed muster
all the way up and down the IRS
uh recognizes this I have been in this
for almost 50 years myself and what that
means is that the church will give the
clergy member a sum of money that will
take care of property tax maintenance
utilities all of
that but then the question arises what
do we do with the old rectory sitting
downtown and some Churches have decided
to rent it
out G money and by the way the money
that they gain from running it out
pretty much becomes the housing
allowance they give to the clergy member
in other words it
washes well some towns are saying oh no
if you've got other people in there
paying rent on that that's an incom
producing property and we don't think
that should be the case we're going to
tax the rectory
now the majority of towns say no we
understand what it's like to have a wash
the rental income you get becomes the
money we use to give the housing
allowance for the clergy member who's
now living out in the suburbs
somewhere this bill would simply say in
law yeah that's what we ought to do but
it will go a little further because what
if a church owns five or six houses well
that's where the court case started the
second richest religious organization in
the world is Trinity Church Wall Street
New York their Church land is not to
taxed the cemetery next door is not
taxed the rectory next door is not taxed
but all those buildings on Wall Street
are owned by Trinity Church and you
better believe they are taxed as any
other building in New York is
taxed so this says both to the churches
if you're just doing this wash it's a
continuation in a way of what you've
been doing and what everybody's been
recognizing for a long time but if you
want to go on buying real estate and
doing various other things that's okay
you can make a profit on it but you're
going to pay real estate tax too so
that's what this seeks to
do thank you
questions representative
Colby thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question um would this
apply to um just a single family
residence or a multif family property
duplex
is there is there a limit to what this
um this property can look like it is
whatever the church or synagogue or
mosque or what have you has been using
in the past traditionally as their
clergy members dwelling and if that's a
a tiny little thing or a bigger thing
the bill makes no distinction on
that F other questions representative
majori thank you madam chairwoman and
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question and and if I understood
correctly it does not seem to matter or
make a difference if it is one lot with
both of those buildings these do not
need to be contiguous Lots they could be
separate lots of record as long as they
are owned by the one entity correct yeah
and I am familiar with a few churches
who for whatever reason lay of the land
topography or whatever cited their
original parsonage around the corner so
would not necessarily have to be
contiguous it would just simply have to
be one unit not a lot of units thank you
yep representative frock is recognized
for a question thank you madam
chairman um
in uh Roman numeral
3B it states that the real estate um
rented to another
organization that shares a similar
Mission or goal shall be
exempt
um organizations don't usually have
residences they would have an office
perhaps and if the organization is then
subletting to a tenant for whatever
reason they want to would the property
then be taxable or not
taxable if it is within the stated
mission of that organization that the
charitable trusts division of Judiciary
and believe me I know them well um says
oh yes this is this is part of your
mission
statement then this is an extension of
that Ministry or organization's purpose
and it would be non-t taxable if it is
not gerain if it is not relevant let's
say the organization who whose purpose
is to provide uh daily comfort for
wounded veterans if they rent it out to
something quite different than that it
would be taxable if it is seen
reasonably seen as a similar Mission
that's tax exempt this is fairly much
what towns have been doing for a
while it just codifies it thank
you further questions
seeing none thank you and I do have uh
written
testimony that
sorry at this time oh there weren't any
more questions I didn't see any yeah we
have another pin card I haven't filled
out pink cards have I yeah you need to
fill one I know that I yell at people
for not doing that
so at this time I have a pink card on
this bill for Mr Jim
Misha good afternoon again committee
members uh for the record Jim misho
Chief assessor of the town of Hudson um
I do have some written
testimony I'm going to focus on how the
bill is written versus the existing law
so
um a good portion of this bill lines 11
through 18 are covered word for word and
House Bill
585 uh which is being heard by house
Ways and Means Committee tomorrow so I'm
not quite sure how two bills basically
doing the same thing get introduced to
two different committees but that's what
happened in regards to lines 8 through
10 in the current proposal
that is already covered under existing
law in my handout I have a clip of
7223 and it says that the real estate
and personal property owned by any
organization described above religious
organizations paragraphs
3 occupied and used by another
organization described in said paragraph
so they're not owning it but they're
using it but they
have the uh similar kind of uh
charitable or religious uh requirement
or or obligation um that that real
estate stays not taxable that's the
meaning of paragraph 5A in
7223 I would argue that the proposal in
this bill actually introduces ambiguity
that doesn't not currently exist in law
um it you know similar Mission or goal
shall be exempt from taxation if if the
language in 5A is not clear I haven't
seen a court case that says the language
in 5A is not clear so I argue that the
words in lines 8 through 11 are not
necessary it's already covered in
statute uh in regards to lines 11
through 18 um this talks about making
sure that if they are renting it out to
an
organization um rents out not more than
one Church parage rather the similar
residential real estate that um the
rental income can only be used for the
following U following points religious
leaders compensation maintenance of the
worship building of par Etc so if the
intention is to add more specificity in
the law then you'll need we should have
the btla be um ordered um to recreate
their form A9 so the local officials can
determine whether or not that rental
income is being used for those
purposes it's introducing more
specificity but we don't have a form
that addresses that kind of
specificity
um I think a lot of the bills that are
that have been introduced on this are
picking at different parts of RSA
7223 I really would encourage the House
and Senate to look at them all together
and determine what parts of the law
should be changed and what's the law
parts of the law should not be because
if we end up doing this peace meal at
the end of it I don't think it's going
to be a law that's going to be able to
be fairly administered at the local
level and I don't think it's going to be
something that the stakeholders are
really going to be happy for happy with
beware of unintended consequences comes
to mind thank
you thank you
questions representative majori thank
you madam chairwoman it may be a
collaborative effort I'm I'm looking to
the chair and and maybe to the chairman
in the room uh so as Mr misho has just
said uh 585 has the same language as in
subsection C here and we have a bill
what happens if is that something that
happens at the clerk level if both these
bills Advance or would there be an
effort on our behalf could there be an
effort on our behalf to collaborate does
anybody
know one fails or if one
fails that that's un that's unclear It's
Curious that we have two bills that
allegedly are essentially the
same so a possible res solution is that
whatever bill or bills advance to the
Senate it could be
resolved um in the other
chamber beyond that um I would have to
inquire further
questions seeing none thank
you at this time the chair recognizes
representative man to report out the
blue
sheets thank you madam chair uh the
remote sign in had three in support and
13 in
opposition and the blue sheet today has
one neutral and one in
opposition thank you and with that the
chair closes the hearing on House
Bill
425 425 is
home we are slightly ahead of schedule
so we will need to wait
approximately five
minutes
e
e e
next on our schedule we have a bill
scheduled for 150 and with with that I
will open the public hearing on House
Bill 421 FN relative to notice of tax
exempt status filing procedures by Town
officials or
offices I would like to welcome
representative Pearson to introduce the
bill to the committee
thank you madam chairwoman members of
the committee to pick up on an earlier
Point having been a chairman for several
years now I have experienced on many
occasions getting two or three or four
bills on roughly the same subject I have
said why didn't they get their act
together uh people have said that about
the New Hampshire legislature for a long
time the simple fact is sometimes we
don't know what somebody else is doing
I've often thought this should should be
a clearing house but I didn't say that
too loudly or I would be named to run it
but so I understand that and you know I
think most of us are flexible we'll work
on stuff you get some ideas we can get
it done this is a similar
Bill and there's going to be an
amendment because
[Music]
um the bill as you look at it does not
quite
reflect what I
wanted I'll only say that so the
amendment makes it what I wanted here's
the thing again for
forever sometime around April the town
wants you to fill out a few forms send
them in that demonstrates why you should
keep your tax exempt
status most nonprofit
organizations have a volunteer team
they're probably pretty good at their
mission they're not necessarily so good
at the business of running an
organization as a result sometimes
people
forget I remember standing in the men's
room with Bill Gardner secretar State he
looks over at me and said haven't got
your
report I said how late are we two
years I said oh my gosh we're dead and
he said
if I came at all the nonprofits that
didn't fill out the Farms the way they
should and shut them down half the
charitable work in estate would die but
you got to get the farm in will you yes
sir so I did and that was the attitude
you know unless this somebody that
really looks kind of sleazy most of
these organizations are just trying to
do good for
people and sometimes we
forget normally a town I understand will
send out notice usually about now middle
of February saying this is due on pick a
date April
15th and they'll tell you you have to
have the what is it 9 81 some of those
and so we'll find somebody who can fill
them out and make them look like they
did last year since nothing's changed
and send them in and all as
well sometimes I forgot and I'd get a
call from Kingston Town Hall saying you
got to get your for and sorry I'm sorry
and they said all right just fil and
drive it up and I
would sometimes I didn't get a
form and since I'm not a very good
administrator if they didn't tell me I
wouldn't have remembered from last year
but get the form filled out and send it
in and that worked sort of pretty well
most of the time you know Bill Garder
comment to me the town halls comment to
me but once again in response to the
court case some towns are tightening up
last year I didn't get a letter from the
town so I didn't send in the
forms I eventually did sending in the
same forms I did the previous several
years but although I never had to send
in a 990 for one of the similar
organizations that uses our land I never
did and they came back to me and said
where's the 990 on there I said I know
what a 990 is why do you need it well
it's required I said okay I'll get it to
you that led to a discussion and I've
had this discussion with some Town
officials elsewhere and some leaders of
nonprofits saying can't we just codify
it can't we just say that 60 days ahead
of the forms
being do you got to send us a letter and
you got to tell us exactly what you want
and if you forget that's okay just don't
penalize
us if you forgot and you know we didn't
remember we'll get the forms in nobody's
out to con anybody you've always said
we're tax exempt so that's what this
bill before you as amended seeks to do
the language in what you have before you
is
confusing the language in the amendment
that I'll be passing around to you says
what I I wanted to to say so that's very
simple just let us know and we'll do the
best we can and if somehow you forget
don't revoke our tax exempt status we're
doing a lot of good work here and we're
would' rather use that money that comes
in to do good for the people of the
Town that's that's just what this seeks
to
do thank you representative Pearson will
you be passing that Amendment out now so
we could take a look chair
did you plan to speak to the
amendment only to say that the amendment
better much better describes what I have
just said
than the original bill as that came out
of OS
questions while the amendment is being
passed
around really oh yeah this is my copy
thank
you said nothing else has a
paper I can provide paper clips
representative if you wish
representative Elward thank you Madame
chairman representative Pearson thank
you for taking my
question
um I'm a do
gooder I had a
501c3 for that I founded for 10 years
and operated for 10 years I'm
sorry
um and we found a a pro bono
CPA who did our informational
filings would you give me that person's
contact information offline please we
also had a pro bono attorney firm Law
Firm that um made sure that we were in
order there's a thing called called a
calendar that you can write deadline
dates
on and I'm I'm
just this is rubbing me just a little
bit the wrong way I think it puts a
burden on the
municipalities um for having to do what
is the organization's
responsibility which is to remember when
the deadline and is what what you need
to file so whereas I I think this this
is
laudable I'm just a little miffed that
these
organizations want a bit of
a pass you know and and putting the
burden on the towns to to WR remind
them I'll take that as a question um I
would mostly agree with you uh that's a
would you believe uh and I would mostly
agree with you and if you saw my office
you would see several sticky notes
reminding me exactly of this but I will
say in the terms of the
990 uh nothing had changed in our
organization in years if they wanted us
to have a 990 we would have provided it
but when we turned in the paperwork that
last year and there was not a 990
attached that was not our fault if they
wanted it they should have told us and
we would have been happy to comply so I
kind of take your point but um not all
501c3 charitable organizations are as
blessed as yours Wass that have all
these pro bono
people this is if the tone of this
sounds what defiant I really don't mean
it to be that I want us to be good
citizens the town officials want to be a
good citizen too I mean Kingston's a
wonderful place especially after they
refunded my tax bill and we're just
trying to set some some
encouragements in different
directions short follow followup yes
what about posting legal notice in a
publication instead of having to I mean
I can't imagine there's hundreds of
organizations within a community that
would you know have to receive a mailing
but what about posting notice instead of
having to do a mailing of a letter at at
the expense at that expense our
wonderful County newspaper folded last
year okay um we didn't know we had to do
a few other things and um secretary
Garder and I had nice little chat and
our friends over to charitable trust
which by the way is a wonderful
organization to deal with because they
just want to get the stuff done right
they're not out for blood and uh I think
the best quote I receiv received from
Diane quinland retired head of
charitable trust
was Sir we deal with people like you a
lot I took that as a compliment and I
think it was meant as one they were very
helpful but yeah we're
learning thank you you're
welcome representative
Colby thank you for taking my question
um how how would a municipality
um be alerted to a
nonprofit being in town initially yes so
um you know a nonprofit moves into town
um how how does how did the assessors
know that they have set up shop there
that's when just about everybody myself
included would have a lawyer helping you
do the paperwork do it with the state
what is required who to notify and so on
and that's what we did when we set it up
is we had a lawyer do that work for us
um most of the charitable organizations
in what I like to call metropolit in
Kingston um have done that when they
started um what we're referring to here
is mostly the annual update stuff where
we don't have a
lawyer follow up
yes thank you I guess what I'm trying to
refer to is similar um to representative
Alward is
accountability it it feels like the
accountability is all being placed onto
the municipality are onto the assessing
office um
when I'm and I'm trying to figure out
you know as a select person how this
would work in my community right how
would I how would I protect myself uh in
the town I would say well we should send
these out certified mail well we just
put together a a bill that would you
know incent it off to the house that
would reimburse a municipality that cost
um for certified mail so I guess I'm
just I'm trying to understand where the
accountability is I think it's mutual
and I think the tone of a charitable
organization in a town whose leaders are
people of Goodwill is that there wants
to be a mutuality there this I do not
see this as a judical thing
primarily the attitude is Friends
helping
friends um I just received four because
I'm chairman of the board of four 501
c3s and I just received four separate
letters from the Secretary of State
saying such and such a report is due no
later than December 31st of this year in
our office thank you sir
photocopies all over the place in case I
lose the original stickies on the wall
and so on but I can't guarantee I would
have thought to do that so I appreciate
it it is really asking friends to be
friends so we can be friends too that's
that's just what I want and most of the
time Kingston did
that and the one year they didn't they
called me and
said the second time that happened
several years later I got a tax bill
which they they were funded and nobody
got angry we all sort of took a deep
breath and realized in the aftermath of
this law suit maybe there's been a
little
overreach and I'm not going to say
whether there was or not I'm just going
to say let's let's go back to the
Friends being friends like we used to
have only get something down on
paper further
questions representative
grundt thank you madam chairwoman thank
you for taking my question um in the
original Bill your last line 11 and well
11 and 12 so last two lines second last
says but no so no such application shall
be received or exemption granted after
the local tax rate has been approved for
that year your Amendment does not have
that in there that's right because if
they're really
late in getting a notification to
us and I'm scrambling around say say oh
my gosh we're late we're late we're late
and their response is too late that kind
of takes out the whole purpose of having
you got to send us a letter
please so there's an incentive
there um we didn't get our tax bill this
past year until well after the tax
deadline but when we sat down together
as friends being friends they realized
okay we'll give you your money back we
should have you should have don't do it
again which believe me with the stickies
in my office we're not going to do this
again but that's the thing is if if you
miss something you miss something up
here we can't be
penalized and when your T the tax you
know we spend $8,000 on our tax bill I
don't know what minuscule percentage
that is in the budget of the town of
Kingston but you got to have a bunch of
zeros after the decimal before you get a
crooked number so even if it's after the
tax rate with it will not in any way
affect the tax rate to people okay thank
you representative Gilman is recognized
for a question thank you madam chair and
thank you for taking my question um the
original bill has a fiscal note and so
the amendment also has a fiscal note and
I'm assuming it's the same fiscal
note which I would say so there there's
I don't think there's anything you know
in my experience with dealing with FNS I
I don't see that there was anything
materially different other than a
cleaning up of deadline language in the
amendment that would make a
difference followup Madam chair yes okay
so the amount of money that's uh that's
talked about in here is for just the one
example or for the
state is that state income tax that
that's uh not
being well the fiscal impact is less
than 10,000 of
what yeah it's probably the cost of a
postage stamp to send us the letter
which has not yet exceeded $10,000 but
it's on the way thank you thank
you for other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you thank you committee
next the chair calls Mr Jim
Misha good afternoon again committee
members Madam chair Jim Mish show town
of Hudson I do have written testimony on
this bill and I can only go based upon
the bill that was uh that was that was
before today I don't have the amendment
um so you know I read a bill literally
like what the words say so this bill
proposes to put the veritable cart
before the horse this bill would require
municipalities to annually mail lines 4
through 5 a form to all organizations
and entities exempt from property
taxation within the community but how do
we know which Comm which
organizations would be exempt it's an
unknown we know what the prior years was
so if the intent was for the community
to mail it out to those entities that
got it in the prior
year we could do that um Hudson
voluntarily does that uh January is we
would have done it by now but BT Board
of tax land appeals is redoing their
forms A9 and a12 in part because of
legislation from last year um
introducing accident mistake Misfortune
uh for a12 um
so uh number two um what is a form if
the form being reference is the btla
form um as called for an RSA 7223 C
annual list
then maybe the legislation should say
the form that the board of tax and land
appeals sends out you know and 7223 C
the form should be described right in
some manner or referen to some state
agency that's responsible for doing the
form um that would help
um so further line four says all
organizations exempt under this section
so that would be all the governmental
organizations the ones that don't even
have to apply have to get the full form
that's the way the proposal reads the
counties The Village districts State
University probably not intended that's
the way the bill
reads uh the proposal in line six states
to send the form out by April 1st with a
deadline of April 15th that's probably
not enough time probably should have the
community send it out a lot maybe two
months before April 15th um again in
Hudson we typically send it out in
January
um even though we do send that form out
we still don't get things timely so we
send the form out again way before the
deadline then we send out a certified
mail again that's our choice right as
municipality you can choose to do that
versus legislation that requires you to
spend the money um and the certified
mail usually does um get get the
person's attention we also use thing
called phone you know we call people up
um let's see lines 5 through eight the
form shall note all documents that must
be submitted to the city of town by the
organization entity to establish
eligibility um so form A9 um does
contain uh information that it asks for
the form literally says organizational
documents nature of membership functions
property and the nature of the property
such of information as shouldas
reasonably required so there is a
description of the forms on the btla
form A9 in regards to the charal
organizations btla form a12 and I've
included all this um it describes the
material needed um it says uh must file
a statements of his financial condition
uh statement is due annually before June
1st um says include the IRS form 990 I
mean all this information is given to
the taxpayer on that
form so um in addition to that the btla
has gone through a number of communities
and um you know really investigating
whether or not entities are getting
exemptions which they're not qualified
for um in the course of that and that's
the next to last paragraph my second
page the btla has developed a checklist
of documents that communities uh should
take a look at and request so maybe that
should be formalized in the statute or
maybe the btla should be encouraged to
formalize that on the A9 or a12 um
that's kind of an ad hoc thing from the
btla
communities are are following the law
the way it's written um I don't know
about days gone by when law didn't exist
but we're trying to follow the law we're
being held accountable by the judicial
system to follow the law so um I I don't
know about you know we can just forgive
deadlines and stuff that would be called
not following the law and if I go to BT
and say that they're going to laugh at
me as they should follow the law follow
the deadlines um other than that I I can
answer any questions you
have thank you for your testimony
questions seeing none thank
you that was a last pink card that I had
so I will ask right now is there anyone
present who wishes to speak on the bill
who has not yet had the opportunity to
do
so okay
um so why don't you provide your
testimony and then you can fill that
pink card out after
welcome to Municipal and County
government you made
it thank you very much um I experienced
the need for this last year because
excuse me excuse me I'm sorry is this
representative gay gay gay well I'm just
honorable now okay so Betty gay from
Salem and uh we experienced the need for
this just this past year because we
learned
about
um let's
see okay our churches and other um other
charitable organizations like American
legent had never been taxed before on
their
property and some of them had new
leadership so that the new people didn't
know about the forms that you have to
submit by I think there are two forms I
haven't had to fill them out myself so
I'm trying to remember one of them is by
the is in April and one is in June so
these new people didn't know about the
forms and then the churches also had
never had some had an assessor come and
walk their property and decide whether
every square foot was used for church
purposes and when they got the tax bills
they were pretty late in the year pretty
soon pretty close just a couple of
months from the time that the tax uh
rate was going to be set because once
the tax rate is set you cannot do
anything but pay the tax and then appeal
and so what the churches did
somehow they came up with several
thousand dollar paid the tax and then
luckily in our town the council agreed
that was not appropriate and they did
get the money back but I don't know how
many churches could do that just write a
check for
$68,000 or more and uh then wait to get
it back so we learned a couple of things
that were disturbing one is that if you
had a new organization or somebody the
person who' been commander of the
American Legion had finally retired so
he probably took care of it all the time
new Commander didn't know anything about
it so here they were told that they owed
all his
tax then the churches had never been
taxed before on their
property and uh some were afraid if
since they only got charged
$100 they didn't want to say anything
because they were afraid they'd go
realize they had several more Acres of
property that they might raise the tax
on others
said well we didn't get taxed because
part of our property is a memorial
garden and that's considered a a
cemetery so we didn't get taxed so we'll
just pretend it's not happening cuz we
let out then the church right next door
has a lot of wetlands a lot of
trees several
Acres they got
hammered and we couldn't even believe
that the church that got just $100 of
tax they were being taxed on their
Wetland their
trees then another church the minister
walked around with the assessor who's
saying well what do you use this for
well they actually in the woods they had
a path so he could say well we'll use
that they says what do you use the grass
for there was a playground on that gr
exuse me honorable representative gay so
I I hear that you're providing testimony
on um assessing and not notification
could you could you get back to that
okay well the important thing was nobody
would have gotten trapped if they had
been notified that they needed to submit
the papers the two documents on one time
so this way if the if the town is
obligated to send it then that won't
happen again and uh the the other issue
about paying taxes is of course in in
other bills so I apologize for wandering
into all the subjects at the same
time thank you
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you so much
so I do believe that was the final
speaker on this bill so the chair
recognizes representative Gilman to
report out the blue
sheet thank you madam chair uh in in the
remote sign up there were three in
support of this bill eight opposed and
on today's blue sheet we had uh one
neutral and one
opposed thank you and with that I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
FN
right for
next on our schedule we have House Bill
782 schedule for 210 so at this time I
will open the public hearing on House
Bill 782 FN expanding property tax
exemptions for certain elderly and
disabled persons raising public
awareness regarding tax credits and
exemptions and requiring ing an annual
report regarding the efficacy of the low
and moderate income homeowner homeowners
property tax relief
program I do not
see okay I do not see the prime
sponsor representative majority yes hi
would someone like to um introduce the
bill sure
thank you madam chairwoman and honorable
members of Municipal and County
government for the record I am Jim
majori representing Rockingham 23 the
wonderful residents of the town of
Northampton here to introduce House Bill
782 FN expanding property tax exemptions
for certain elderly and disabled persons
raising public awareness regarding tax
credits and exemptions and requiring an
annual report regarding the efficacy of
the low and moderate income homeowners
property tax relief program happy to
take all of your questions I will answer
them very
thoroughly thank you for that bill
introduction
questions seeing none thank
you at this time the chair recognizes
Jim misho
welcome back again thank you madam chair
and committee members Again Jim M show
Chief assessor for the town of Hudson I
do have written uh testimony um in
regards to the first section first
section requiring municipalities to post
instructions on how to apply um so there
already is an RSA RSA 76 colon 11 that
speaks to notice of property tax relief
programs I've attached that law and that
requires us to print on the taxx bill
stated language right the statutory
language that talks about exemption
programs for them to apply for tax
credits um so in in semiannual tax bill
communities uh folks receive it directly
from by first class mail right US Post
Office so um in addition to that between
web pages uh people's uh Community media
cable uh the newspaper um there's a lot
of notification about tax relief
programs um so I think that it's outside
of handl it to people at their front
door as opposed to using the post office
I think there already is quite a bit of
notification about the awareness of
these programs um in regards to um
sections 3 four and five disabled deaf
and elderly um seeks to raise the
optional disabled exemption amounts um
so sorry the asset amounts um I've
listed on the last paragraph of page one
um there's about 111 communities that
have the disabled exemption that's an
optional exemption um you're not
required to adopt it uh the asset range
is 35,000 to 500,000 the median asset
limit is 65 the average asset amount is
93,471
in regards to um tying the asset amounts
or exemption amounts uh to an automatic
CPI index that's new right so that's we
don't have that in law um someone can
make an argument that uh tying it in
automatically removes the will of the
voters right I mean if we want to raise
the amount then voters have a choice to
do that and uh you know selectman former
government um so having an automatic
escalator um you could say takes away
the will of the voters maybe that maybe
they want to have that decision
themselves uh sections 7 through 13
involve State program no comment on that
and uh sections 14 through 15 a
far-reaching study commission appears
that there's uh fairly significant
Municipal stakeholder and other
practitioners involvement uh that would
be contemplated so that's the extent of
my
comments thank you for your testimony
questions representative Colby
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I'm just looking for
a recommendation um multiple times
within the bill it it states um an
amount not less than which shall be
adjusted for inflation annually based
upon the Bureau of Labor Statistics
Consumer Price Index Northeast region it
doesn't give us a date would you have a
date that you would suggest
that um you could say the last prior
quarter right or the last prior annual
okay um if that something that that the
committee feels should have that in
there um you know just annually the
community would need to make sure it did
that right so I would have to plug it
into the mass appraisal system tax has
to have it in their system um we we
would do it right so we're required to
do it but that's a good good comment
that's actually in my written testimony
I didn't know what time period that CPI
was going to grab from and should every
Community um for the ease of assessing
purposes and and the Department of
Revenue Administration adopt the same
day I imagine that if the proposal was
had the specification added it would be
the same specification for each
community that chose to adopt the
exemption would be that same specified
CPI typ frame great thank age thank
you representative Guthrie is recognized
for a question thank you madam chairman
thank you for taking my question you
mentioned the uh in adjusted for
inflation that that was the problem uh
would you would I be correct in saying
that when the adjustment was made to
increase the the original increase
couldn't that be part of the warrant
article that that in the warrant article
it would say that the adjustment would
be made couldn't you do it that way
thank you for the question
representative if I understand the
question
correctly you'd have to have an annual
under current law you'd have to have an
annual warrant article to establish what
the asset amount should
be there is no provision currently this
is proposing to add a provision but
there's no provision currently for that
just to be an
automatic increase in the asset amount
based upon some Metric it would be
outside the bounds of current law a
community were to do that in such a
formal Fashion on a Warren article I
know if I may I know Town Council
communities that say each year this is
what we're going to do but each year
they make they they vote on that new
number so there's an annual election to
do that am I not follow up mam CH
so the legislative body couldn't just
say in the Warren article that we're
going to adjust this every
year don't you don't think that would
pass buer I I don't think that the
current language allows for it and since
we're a Dylan rule state municipalities
can only do what the legislature allows
us to do and I don't see anywhere in the
legislation that says you can do this
automatic it just does it on its own
unless this were to pass this this
section okay thank you thank you
for representative
Gilman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question I think to
follow up on representative Guthrie's
question
um in well sb2 town anyway we need to
give the number that we're raising an
appropriating
so if the if it's
50,000 plus must plus or minus the
Consumer Price Index then um we don't
know what that appropriation will be in
subsequent
years is that is that problem thank you
for the thank you for the question I I
don't really I don't believe it's an
appropriation of money it's a
description of the exemption amount or
it's a description of the asset
amount representative majori thank you
madam chairwoman and thank you for
taking my question um in in your opinion
might this also be binding future select
boards which is something you can't do
thank you for the
question this this would uh this would
seem to override the local
authorities approach to raising or
adjusting how much that exemption amount
should
be additional
questions seeing none thank
you thank
you so that was my last pink card for
this bill so I will ask is there is
there anyone present who wishes to speak
on the bill who has not yet had the
opportunity to do so seeing none the
chair recognizes representative Gilman
to report out the blue sheet thank you
madam chair on the remote sign in we had
two in support and 14 in
opposition and today's blue sheet is
somewhere
today's blue sheet shows one uh neutral
and one uh
opposed thank you and with that the
chair closes the public hearing ing on
House Bill 782
FN so we are um about 10 minutes ahead
of schedule so we will wait until 2:40
to open our last public hearing for the
day
e e
e
the time is now 2:40 p.m. and the chair
will open the public hearing on House
Bill 458 FN limiting local assistance to
United States citizens or permanent
legal
residents I do not see the prime sponsor
present to introduce the bill would
somebody like to introduce the
bill representative
Elward good afternoon
committee
members um for the record my name is
Deborah Elward I represent marac
District 5 which is Andover danburry
Hills Salsbury and Webster I'm here to
introduce House Bill
FN an act limiting local assistance to
US citizens or permanent legal residents
thank
you are you going to answer you don't
need to answer questions no okay you're
all
set
yeah so next the chair calls I believe
it's attorney Steven
Tower good afternoon and welcome to
Municipal and County Government
afternoon is that better all right much
better good afternoon I'm Steve Tower
I'm an attorney at New Hampshire Legal
Assistant I uh lead our local welfare
project um I had email Ed representative
Roy about this bill uh earlier on and um
I had assumed that the intention of this
bill was to prevent undocumented
immigrants from accessing local welfare
and and and that that was a major
concern and I uh I wanted to point out
that existing federal law which I'm
circulating around prohibits um most uh
immigrants particularly undocumented
immigrants from accessing any state
benefits um the exceptions are for
qualified aliens under federal law or
certain types of nonimmigrant aliens um
and in those instances States may allow
them to receive access to state benefits
but they may also restrict access to
state benefits um now representative
Roy's bill would limit access to local
welfare for just US citizens and
permanent residents but under federal
law as I'm circulating around uh uh
chapter 8 USC sections I believe it's
1622 um there is a list of exceptions
that a state must allow to access state
benefits and those exceptions include
people who are approved as Asylum
Seekers uh for the first five years that
they are granted Asylum people who are
approved as refugees for the first 5
years and and so that's required by
federal law um in the draft as
provided uh these number of exceptions
which also include uh aliens that have
served in the US military or are
currently in active duty in the US
military States also must allow them
access to state benefits um these are
not currently included in the law so to
the bill so to comply with federal law
the bill would at least need to include
those enumerated exceptions that are in
8 USC section
1622 um and if you look at it it's it's
kind of a long and lengthy set of except
exceptions that refer to certain
sections of the immigration and
nationality act um and uh if if you were
to include all of these listed out
exceptions in the local Welfare Law it's
going
to be fairly complicated to look at and
read I'll note um the local welfare
administrators Association puts out
model rules and guidelines for towns to
adopt and in the the guidelines they do
include a section about the eligibility
for uh non-citizens that summarizes the
federal requirements that I've
circulated around um so that is
currently in the guidelines for uh the
recommended guidelines for
towns
um there are also two categories of
individuals which a state may deny local
welfare benefits to or or any other
state benefit to that uh while a state
may deny access to those two groups um
for uh humanitarian and Law and Order
reasons I I would ask this committee to
consider including those as allowable to
receive local welfare benefits those are
people who are defined under uh uh 8 USC
uh section
1101 part 15 T and U as you can see
federal laws gets a little complicated
when you're talking about immigration
but tnu refer to uh people who are
eligible for visas because they are a
victim of human trafficking or other
serious crimes and are cooperating with
authorities for the investigation or
prosecution of the people who committed
those crimes and where the US Attorney
General's office has recognized that
they are in fact doing that and are
eligible for a Visa so that they can be
available to go after those criminals um
and I think it would undermine the
Federal Law and Order purpose of going
after these criminals uh if a person
could obtain a visa to be here and and
be available to help uh law enforcement
go after these folks but then would have
be denied the possibility of maintaining
basic survival LEL of care uh in the
state um so I I I would ask that the at
a minimum the committee try to include
those to as
eligible um but for the purposes of
clarity it may be more effective for
this bill to be drafted to enumerate
specifically which types of immigrants
uh the committee wishes to prohibit from
accessing local welfare say uh
immigrants who have no recogn legal
status by the federal government or
something like that it would be a nice
short addition into the RSA 165 statute
as opposed to
a eight paragraph inclusion of all these
Federal exceptions under 8 USC
1622 um but I think that's the extent of
my testimony and I just wanted to point
out that there is some requirements in
federal law that are not currently
included in this
bill and I'm happy to take questions
I'll note that I am not an immigration
expert by any stretch of the imagination
I had not looked at any of this until I
looked at this bill so uh I can do my
best to answer questions but um I may
have to say that I don't know thank you
attorney Tower um the chair recognizes
representative Murphy for a
question thank you madam chair thank you
attorney um do you have the welfare
guidelines for this committee so we can
look at those um I did print out the one
page and so these are the model
guidelines each town can adopt their own
guidelines um and the model guidelines
are put together by the municipal
Association and the local welfare
administrators Association as a
recommended best practices to possibly
uh help towns avoid getting into any
legal issues with bad unlawful
guidelines um and so I did not bring a
copy of those model guidelines I did
bring the one page from the model
guidelines that references eligibility
for non-citizens and I can circulate
that one page but I don't have the full
guidelines with me thank you further
questions seeing none thank
you at this time I don't have any
additional pink cards but yes okay
no problem um just introduce yourself
for the record who you represent in your
position and good afternoon and welcome
to Municipal and County government thank
you thank you and thank you for the
position or the opportunity to present
testimony uh my name is Bill gillet I'm
the director of public policy and
advocacy for The International Institute
of New England uh which is a refugee
resettlement and immigration support
organization and we have been operating
in Manchester since the early
1980s uh I wasn't planning actually on
speaking today but I did want to just
add to the testimony that you've already
heard including the written testimony uh
and I'm available for any questions uh I
I just want to emphasize one uh one
point here and that is you've heard the
legal rationale here and there's in in
addition very good uh written testimony
on the legal standards here but I wanted
to address why the situation and why
certain immigrants uh should be eligible
and are eligible under the federal law
for this type of assistance um let me
talk about refugees and ases and by ases
I mean people who have already been
granted Asylum these are individuals who
have been lawfully admitted to the
country they are fully authorized to
work here they are fully authorized to
live here and they are on a path to uh
permanent residence and citizenship from
the time that they are here when a
refugee comes to the country and by the
way the refugees that come here are the
most vetted immigrants who come into
this country it can be up to a two-year
process uh when they arrive in the
United States they are then and when an
asylum Seeker is granted Asylum they are
then uh required to apply for a green
card within one year that process can
take up to three years for the
processing of the green card but they
are on a path to
citizenship um for the most part the
refugee program is been very successful
and it's quite rare that they are
accessing this type of assistance but
the fact that they are here for the most
part they're working they are an active
part of our society and as I say they
are on a direct path to citizenship
means that they should be able to take
advantage of those programs that provide
for the needy in our
society thank you I I I don't want to
take up any more of the committee's time
but I in some respects I am an
immigration expert and I'm happy to take
any questions thank you for your
testimony
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very
much no you you'll fill out your card um
so that I don't have any additional pink
card so I will ask is there anyone
present who wishes to speak to this bill
who has not yet had the opportunity to
do
so seeing none the chair will recognize
representative Gilman to report out the
blue sheets thank you madam chair uh
online testimony uh showed 14 in support
of the bill and
173 uh opposed to the bill and I have to
say one of those 173 just wants clean
air and the paper blue shet shows one
opposed thank you and with that the
chair will close the public hearing on
House Bill 458
FN so at this point that concludes our
publicly noticed business for today but
before we adjourn there are some
afternoon
announcements so first as a reminder
there is a house session scheduled for
Thursday February 6th at 10:00
a.m. also please hold Thursday February
13th and Thursday February 20th open for
possible future house
sessions the week of February 9th plan
to meet on Monday February 10th for
hearings and executive session that is
to be scheduled but that's what I'm
looking um to do the week of February
23rd please plan to meet on Tuesday
February 25th for hear heing hearings
only and at this time um the chair will
form a subcommittee for House Bill 432
relative to recovery houses because
there was interest in forming a
subcommittee to do further um study and
inquiry with regards to that particular
bill so the subcommittee um will be
comprised of three Republicans and two
Democrats so at this time the chair
appoints Representatives McDonald Dolan
and
Walker and also representatives frock
gerana representative McDonald will
serve as the chair of the subcommittee
and he will be responsible for calling
subcommittee
meetings does anybody have any
questions yes yes thank you um does does
the subcommittee have to report at the
same time that the that the bill is due
with the deadline for the bill being due
or does the subcommittee have more time
I probably should look that up myself my
understanding is that the subcommittee
is a subset of the committee that does
further inquiry with regards to the bill
and then that information is brought
forward to the entire committee um at
the executive session for input um and
consideration
for executing that particular
bill so
um I hope that answers the your question
it does just so I okay and did
representative Gilman did you have a
question yes just can you please repeat
the meeting dates for us just the the
committee okay so I'm looking at it has
not yet been scheduled but and it all
depends on room Ava availability the
week of February 9th planed to meet on
Monday February 10th and that is for
hearings and executive session and then
that last week in February which is the
week of February
23rd we will need to meet and I'm
looking at Tuesday February 25th and
that's in order to meet house deadlines
and that will be for hearings only thank
you okay further
questions
okay so um with that the
chair calls the the meeting here today
adjourned thank you and have a great
week